this is Jocko podcast number 135 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing good
evening echo good evening dear mrs.
spearing there is grief in my heart and
in the hearts of all my comrades for the
great sorrow that this war has brought
to you and to us we all unite to express
our heartfelt sympathy and condolence to
the mother and family of one who has
fallen in a cause as imperishable as
will be the names of those who have
fallen to defend it should there be
anything my comrades and I can do to
mitigate your grief and to allay your
sorrow some little keepsake of Walt as a
marine perhaps but name it dear lady and
it shall traverse the ocean to you
because you do not know me please do not
think it presumptuous for me to write
you are Walter's mother
I was his inseparable friend and comrade
that makes us two kindred souls in
common grief for our nearest and dearest
then to this letter fulfills my duty
that I am bound by oath and will to
perform many months ago Walt and I
promised each other that should the god
of battles call to one the other would
console the sorrowing mother now Walt
has gone west to home and to you forever
but his figure his voice his wonderful
personality will always be living truths
to me I myself
the great call come we'll go gladly
confident of a reunion and with faith in
the eternal truth of that cause for
which I died beneath the green in Bella
woods forever connected to the honor of
the Marines lies waltz with his two
comrades dead on the field of Honor
above their graves the stately pines
sway in their grandeur an imperishable
monument but greatest of all epitaphs is
that engraved within the hearts of his
comrades a man then whom there was no
peer in kind leanness in understanding
in comradeship beyond compare we alone
know what could have been had
circumstances so willed it whatever
befall whatever sorrow fills us one
thing I swear to you here hard by that
lonely grave the very paper that I write
upon taken in a captured German dugout I
swear that Walt is well avenged that he
has died not in vain for his spirit
leads us on to ultimate victory you are
proud I know for you are the mother of a
martyr a martyr in a holy cause freedom
and liberty
dear lady the very thought that you are
in grief tears my heart do not sorrow
death after all is not so terrible and
here why here it is glorious mother in
the name of the 23rd company in the name
of the Marines I salute you and all my
comrades salute you devotedly saw
seagull and that was a letter written by
saul seagull it was an O three thirty
three heavy machine gunner he was twenty
years old when he wrote that letter at
the graveside of his marine corps
brother Walter spearing was his name who
was from Philadelphia who had been
amongst the earliest of the Marines to
ship over the war and who was one of the
1811 Americans killed at the Battle of
belleau wood and Walter spearing died on
June 26 1918 and as he said that letter
was written on captured paper from a
German dugout and you hear that writing
that articulate that that poetic writing
by a 20 year old Marine Corps machine
gunner and it's a letter that captures
so many different aspects of war and in
capturing different aspects of war it
teaches us teaches us about leadership
it teaches us about human nature teaches
us about suffering it teaches us about
death and it teaches us about life and
tonight back here again to talk to us
about all those different subject as a
marine that I was honored to serve with
on the battlefield and who I am now
honored to work with once again on a
different front his name is Dave Burke
he's been on the podcast before already
so if you haven't heard that one
it was podcast number 69 and you should
listen to that one first to hear about
Dave's incredible background as a Marine
Corps f-18 fighter pilot f-16 pilot f-22
pilot f-35 pilot Top Gun pilot Top Gun
instructor Top Gun senior instructor and
of course anglich Oh team leader on the
ground with us in the Battle of Ramadi
and if you've listened to podcast 69
then you can hear all about that and
tonight a little deeper on all these
different subjects Dave thanks for
coming back on the show thanks jack um
so to be here man
you just find these letters like that
and it's it's incredible I know I was
like hey read this and you know your
reactions like this is a 20 year old
Marine is it a different time is it the
language is different back then
yeah and the language is different and
if you just hear the words it sounds
like a completely different world and
then when you think about what he's
saying I know exactly what you can you
can feel what he's feeling and it comes
through so so clearly and and I've read
letters like that I've heard you read
letters like that I've seen letters like
that and I've written a letter like that
it didn't sound that eloquent it didn't
but I know that feeling and it's
incredible that after all this time how
powerful that comes through man it was
that's awesome as you and this is
another thing that you and I were
talking about these lessons that exists
in history in literature and and it's
funny because it's it's things that are
written by privates it's things that are
written by corporals it's things that
are written by majors and Colonels and
Generals and it's things that are
written by emperors and it's things that
are written by conscripts and everything
in between and every time I every time I
even that right there it's like I get
another angle to appreciate and to
realize and then you start you know you
started I'll cover Bela wood on this
podcast for sure but I mean when you
read about Bella wood at all it was just
savage battle yeah savage battle I mean
there's one Medal of Honor for a guy
that just his buddy didn't have his gas
mask so he took off his own gas mask and
gave it to him and then and then died I
mean it's it's it's unbelievable
and so you were telling me you kind of
opened back up to the history books the
war books yeah I used to certainly as a
kid and early in my career I
military history all the time I mean
some of it was an assignment you know
he'd become a lieutenant the Marine
Corps and there's a kind of a reading
list that you want to go through and you
do some of it kind of they call it
professional military education PME but
I used to be really interested in it and
I just kind of do it on my own a lot of
it was aviation centric but I got away
from it and for the latter half of my
career I didn't do military history at
all it wasn't it just wasn't something
that really captivated me and in the
last year and a half or so partially now
not partially mostly because of this
podcast I've actually gone back and
reread some of the books and and you and
I've talked about a lot of different
ones with the old breed Eugene sledge so
that was a book I read a long time ago
and it was it was incredible book very
powerful but I went back and reread that
book a little while back and I had
stopped thinking and paying attention to
the meanings I was I was I was almost
paying attention to chronology in the
past okay this is happened in here this
is the lesson learned and this is the
movement and it was all kind of very
sanitary and I lost what it meant to
hear their stories and I used to read
them and I think I just tried to pay
attention to what happened and not
really learn as much from him or from
them and and I've read more in the last
a year than I had in honestly occupy the
previous five if not more and I'm
reading all the time and I'm and and
once you start sort of digging into that
world there's there's more books than I
could ever read in my entire life
they're everywhere
and it has renewed the way I the how
much I read but it's also changed the
way I read and it's been a really good
experience for me I've learned a lot in
the last year the and this is another
thing I talk to you about as we were
talking about this subject the other day
and I brought up this quote from Musashi
yeah and and the quote is if you know
the way broadly
you will see it in everything yeah and
to me that is what makes that is what
has I guess recalibrated reading for me
is that when you start seeing all these
connections and everything and and part
of it quite frankly comes from the fact
that I wrote a book that is about this
subject
and once you go that deep in it it's
like okay now I start seeing it
everywhere and I mean even it kind of
all started it it definitely all started
with about face for me with about face
for me when I was in Iraq and I knew I
knew about face was a great book and
this is this is on my second but on my
first employment my book was with the
old breed as a matter of fact that was
my book yeah and I thought okay but it
was so disconnected it was such a
stretch I mean my first deployment to
Iraq was absolutely absolutely nothing
like with the old breed other the fact
that we were American like the
similarities ended there right it was
nothing like with the old breed nothing
you know other than in my mind okay well
these are horrible things that are
happening you just it was really hard to
make that connection I'll tell you what
though our deployment to Ramadi the
similarities between Ramadi and and
about-face were incredible not just you
know one of the things that hit me right
out of the gate is when Hackworth gets
to Vietnam and those guys are getting
killed and they're getting killed by
sniper fire indirect fire and booby
traps right which we now call IEDs for
whatever reason and that one section in
the book where they've taken hundred
something casualties and they've and
they've they've contacted the enemy zero
times it's an enemy killed zero and I'm
thinking to myself this is a nightmare
this is a nightmare and that nightmare
it shows itself over and over and over
again and what's so hard is and I'll
tell you where it hit me again
it hit me again on on Lewis polar when
Lewis polar is rotating between the
three different sections and one of them
was called
Riviera mm-hmm and he's saying every
time they go into Riviera
they take wounded or they take killed
and on top of that they don't ever see
the enemy and I'm thinking myself it's
maddening right it's maddening when you
look back and you're detached which were
detached now and I don't know if culture
is different I don't know if our culture
is different I don't know if we value
human life more I don't know that but
when you read it it's maddening to think
about that and you could see that like
Hackworth he didn't like that he didn't
like that at all and that was wrong that
was I think maybe it was you that told
me when I had Jim ookayama on and or a
couple people told me they were like you
sounded Gibby
yeah and I said well yes I was giddy and
and here I was but it was very
interesting to go and talk to Mookie
Yama because what was interesting to me
is you you there's the there's the
public persona of some guy that was in
the military right right there's the
the military myself included you all of
us there's that public persona of oh
this is what this guy's perceived as but
then there's like okay what about all
the people that served with that person
what do they really think
and what was Hackworth really like and
so going to meet Mook I was very curious
now I had read an interview with him
where I I knew that he had these very he
held him in the highest esteem it didn't
come as a surprise to me but still it
was it was incredible that the
perception that I had of Hackworth was
accurate it was accurate and when you
thought when you heard Mook talk about
it when he said we called them mister
infantry I see I I was just thinking to
myself is there any thing cooler in the
world than to be known throughout the
army as mister infantry yeah you said
something that that that jumped out at
me a little bit you
you were just talking about you know is
is culture different as is something
different so let me just say this a
little bit because you know I've even
thought a little bit about why do I see
things differently than I used to what
why have I evolved in a certain way so
did I spend 23 years in the Marine Corps
23 years as a US Marine and a whole
bunch of years just wanting to be a
Marine
I was in Ramadi for seven months so if
you just kind of do the math that's just
not a lot of time everything I think
about every leadership lesson every when
I hear you talk about a book when I read
a book when I think all of those things
the frame of reference I had the thing I
think about is those seven months and
had I not had those seven months of and
look Ramadi obviously was it could it
was a maddening place it was crazy but
if I didn't have that I don't think I
would be able to appreciate or
understand and without that frame of
reference without that understanding of
some connection to that it actually
makes it difficult and I would have
never guessed that if I were to tell you
hey I'm gonna look up back in my 23-year
career and all those things I heard you
listen to my bio it's always stranger
here's someone read it out the the the
the most powerful thing in that was
seven months in Ramadi that's the thing
that outshines all of it because of what
you just described because of that
feeling and I don't know if it's that
that that culture is different or
societies if until we have different
values we value human life different
differently but without the frame of
reference it can be hard to capture but
if you start to think of it in in a
different way and that's sort of what
that that quote means I don't know this
is kind of a deep thought but that's you
see things differently and you think
about things that and you start to see
things you didn't even know we're there
before and that's why when I went back
and read look I've read a book and I
read the exact same book again and to
see and hear and understand things
differently the same time on a book that
was and for me for me it was with the
old buddy that was the book that sort of
hit me square I got
go to okay now I got to walk that ground
now and to go back and reread that book
recently and have it seem so different
that has really stuck with me and and
and that was sort of the reason why I
got back into reading some of them the
same books is something some are
different but there is something about
that perspective that changes you and I
would have never guessed that throughout
my career always wanted to be a pilot
until ever really wanted to do that I
would sort of define my experience based
on those seven months and how that
influenced everything that I see now and
and the weird thing is about Ramadi is
when you compare Ramadi to Peleliu if
you compare Ramadi to Okinawa you
compare Ramadi to Normandy you compare
Ramadi to you compare Ramadi to those
places and our experience was just it
just pales it just absolutely pales yeah
you and I have talked about this a lot
you actually sent me I think he sent me
a text or an email a couple weeks ago
like hey do me a favor just verify I got
this right I wanted Mitch to make sure I
got your combat experience in in your
first deployment correct and it was that
I was in combat in Iraq and I was
thinking yeah yeah I know you got it all
right I dropped a bomb that's my car
that was a legitimate combat except
that's before that's pre 9/11 9/11 you
know were one of the few guys with
combat combat yeah
that's man you had dropped aa bomb bomb
singular and I thought wasn't just how
ridiculous that sounds but I thought I
don't ever want Charlie Plummer bill
reader to hear me say that yeah I don't
want them to he was almost embarrassed
and and even like you said Ramadi would
which for me which was sort of like the
World Series and the Superbowl combined
into one like the most powerful thing
and with the old breed since we've been
talking about that talk about the Battle
of Okinawa and what they endured I mean
it is so humbling and an almost honestly
man doubt Ryan a little embarrassing to
try to share the same experience we saw
that what Tom Fife and I remember tom 5
was on the podcast and he was so
grateful for he
thanking me for what we had done and
what we accomplished and I'm thinking
this is a man that has a Purple Heart
from World War two Korea and Vietnam and
he's thanking me for what I did and you
know that's that's a frame of reference
that I think is important and something
the podcast does is so trim their wells
it gives those guys a chance to share
that story that otherwise they wouldn't
get a chance to is there a way to get
I'm trying to figure out what I was
missing
right I was trying to figure out what
how can you get somebody that's a 18
year old corporal to read a book with
the perspective that with the right
perspective is that possible an 18 year
old Dave Burke it was impossible I can
tell you that for sure it wasn't and I
don't know if that if that's the case
but I do know that if you get an 18 year
old Dave Burke agent anybody to to start
to read it start to think about it that
actually builds over time and that
creates some sort of foundation that I
think with time of perspective you can
actually reach those reach that but
there's no way at that age no matter
what you said no matter how articulate
you were no matter how powerful the
story was I don't think you're reaching
me and I don't mean that to be
discouraging but I think that's that's a
hard lesson I think you know certainly
what I was going through at that time in
my life it's just not gonna happen it's
gonna it depends too because what you're
focused on when you're 8 yeah then you
read with the old breed you're like like
I remember my earliest memories of with
the old breed are these guys were
ripping people's gold DL with pliers
you're thinking whoa that's crazy like
that's the big that's that's probably
the big takeaway from my first read when
I was whenever years old yep of with the
old breed it's you you see it for the
things that seem not real and you're
like man
that is incredible that is awesome and I
also think that goes that you talk about
a lot that that sort of that feeling of
invincibility to when you're young and
that like immune to not just the
physical risks not just the potential of
getting hurt or getting injured or
getting shot or some of those worst
things but the mental and emotional
risks that go along with experiencing
that that's a really hard lesson now the
other side of that is you know when I
deployed to Ramadi almost everybody on
my team was a first deployment brand new
young US Marine you met Marcus Perez he
came to the muster you know he was a
young kid and you walk in there sort of
with this kind of this bulletproof
approach and it's not how it is when you
leave it's not the same and and in some
ways like you said this scale is is
different than a mana Peleliu or a
Guadalcanal or any of those things you
know that we just talked about but when
it's happening to you it's it could be a
single round a single mortar a single
shot a single wound if it's happening to
you it sort of feels like though it's
happening to the whole world it's really
impactful and that's probably why if I
look back at my career the thing that's
the most powerful experience that I had
that sort of outshines everything by so
much is is that time in Ramadi because I
was exposed to things that I never saw
as a pilot and never would have seen had
I not been on that deployment you know
what I was I was thinking so one of the
things I remember probably I don't know
if it was 10 or 15 podcasts deep into
into this podcast I remember saying
during one of the podcasts and I've said
it a few times along the way I remember
saying that these people that I'm
talking about in these books they're not
characters yeah these are people and I
think at some point for me that
transition in my brain happened where I
was saying to myself these are these are
people
and I think I got a little bit of it in
my platoon commander tour because you
know there was it was it was a good
solid deployment was there risk sure
there was rescue it wasn't super high
risk I had I had a great crew guys but
you know there was there was stress and
there was personalities and you start to
see that when you read about a guy and
you think I kind of know that guy just I
just know him a little bit I just know
him a little bit and and you start to
realize that those people in these books
they're real people and I think that for
me was a huge leap between well
connecting me to the text that I was
reading and I'll tell you another thing
and straight up voice when I started
thinking about reading these things when
I started reading these aloud when I
started reading them and hearing him in
my own headset like on the podcast that
was an impact and and now it's happened
it happened with bill reader it happened
with Joe team it it could happen when
these guys come on here and they hear me
read what they wrote and it hits them
and so that's another part of it too
there is an element when you read that's
missing there's an element of voice that
is just more powerful it's just more
powerful and I remember when I read The
Forgotten Highlander when I read that
book I read it on the plane coming back
calling a guy over in Scotland a buddy
of mine who had done some work with he
gave me this book and I was on podcast
11 and he goes hey you gotta check out
this book I won't try and do it Scottish
accent plus he's a mumbler you know like
check out the book me and so he gives me
this book and I'm sort of thinking okay
you know I just I wasn't sure but I had
made enough of enough of a leap in my
brain that when I started reading that
book I said to myself wow this is gonna
be this is gonna be a really powerful
podcast so I read the book so then when
we come this is podcast number 12 when
we can't when I came in to record it I
thought yeah this is gonna be really
heavy but when I read it it was like I
was getting hit in the head with with a
sledgehammer and that's the first
podcast that when I got to the end of
the book I actually didn't know what
they because what do you say what do you
say about a guy that what do you say
about a guy that that that put maggots
on his flesh to eat away the dead flesh
what do you say about that what do you
say about that and so that's the first
podcast where I said when I got done
with it the next time I did a podcast
that was heavy like that I knew that I
had to get myself somewhere to go I had
to give myself some thought about how am
I gonna make this how does this become
something how do i how do I get out of
this hole because that's what that's
what you're doing and so there's a level
of that as well when you hear like when
you hear a hardcore history podcast the
great storytelling but he's reading
quotes from people but it's so much more
powerful when you hear it audibly and we
you know people say that about extreme
ownership - people say oh yeah I love
that book in this and we'll say you
gotta get the audiobook because it's
life and I reading it and you can hear I
mean how much is communicated in the
tone of voice there's a lot when you
said earlier about the the audible piece
of that when you finish my first podcast
so when I was on is we were talking
about this is almost a year and a half
ago now you know April I think of last
year I guess
you finished with a letter that Kat
wrote to Chris now I didn't know we
hadn't discussed that and I didn't know
how I was gonna finish and you know we
spent all that time you know talking
about me and my experience and things
like that
I knew that letter very well I have a
copy of that letter and I've read that
letter several times I had never read
that letter out loud to myself I never
read it any but as I've shared it you
know with Whitney and I've shared that
letter hearing you say a letter that I
knew almost line by line I know that
letter really well made that letter like
I had never heard it before and I
remember look it's hard to hear because
I it's Chris and it's hard for me
because that's a really impactful thing
very emotional thing and that is a
that's a crusher for me man I know you
understand that but I had never heard
out loud and in there's a book I'm
reading now that I have read the preface
of the book which is only about three
pages kind of explained I've read it out
loud to myself like five times and it
it's it's something that I overlooked
the impact of hearing it as opposed to
reading and I read the book is a really
cool book I think I sent Japan this
book's awesome you should check it out I
read the preface out loud to myself and
having had read it three or four times
already hearing it was like reading it
for the first time the the voice that
you give that makes it makes the words
become real like a like that person
wrote the blows is saying out loud and
that difference there it's not subtle
it's huge it's a huge huge thing that
that is one of the great things about
when people do it when they do it on
podcasts and you're putting somebody
else's voice in action
most of the time we're reading books by
people that are long gone and you're
telling stories that nobody would ever
hear and even if you read them it misses
something and I think the power of that
is huge and it brought me right back to
our last podcast which was you sitting
right where you are reading cat's letter
to Chris and as it like I said like I'd
never heard it before it was it's a
totally different level
you know what podcasts was another
podcast that that sort of it get caught
me was one soldiers war by Arkady and
that part in the end of that podcast
where it's again I said that was podcast
number 18 and he's he's he's quoting
these wounded soldiers that were sitting
begging for money basically and he's
talking about how this guy is saying if
I would kill all these he's talking
about this this soldiers talking about
everyone on the streets in Moscow he
says I would kill every one of these
people to bring back my brothers you
reading this going up
god that is a powerful powerful book did
you see him in the news recently no he
faked his own death oh yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yes all these people we
talked about yeah they hit me up on
social media and I was aw man what a
trap yeah and yeah I was totally bummed
out and then sure enough he had faked
his own death he had even fooled his
wife yeah tell his wife
that's that takes a lot of courage he's
a courageous guy already but yeah to
fake your death and not give your wife a
heads up about it that's that's hardcore
that that's problematic yeah and and
that that feeling do you it's one thing
to sort of have that feeling but to be
willing to express that feeling that I
would do that to all of these people
that is that's a bet saying a lot man I
mean that is deep to to I mean I've had
some pretty hardcore thoughts certainly
in my time like now I'm fine like I
share that one yeah but to put it out
there you know I mean that's that gets
to the core of just how how much people
feel from those experiences how powerful
those feelings are and those guys had no
mercy
those those Russian soldiers they had no
mercy it was that that part where he's
talking about the sergeant's beat the
corporals the captain's beat the
sergeants the majors beat the captain's
yeah it's just a nightmare yeah it's
just a complete nightmare it makes you
wonder how any of that is is makes any
of it remotely functional but how does
that system function at all under that
setting under that environment how could
anybody at the bottom of that hierarchy
be willing to go do any of the things
they went and did you know you're
talking about you know this thing from
from Bella would there they literally
know most of you are gonna die we're
gonna charge across open fields into
machine guns we use that example at
national on front is something that you
would never do and that's what they were
doing
I mean borderline just human waves if we
do it enough we're gonna get 50 75 yards
of terrain out of it we're gonna move
the line forward a hundred yards and
we're gonna send a wave after
wave after wave - and and guys are left
right like this is Bert bordelon a death
sentence what what people are capable of
doing and under those environments is is
unreal
sometimes one moreone it just is it's
just you know you know what's funny is
that I say that about everyone every war
so it won't run like unbelievable and
then you you talk about Napoleon who
like nothing like that and then I read
the book on the coldest war or colder
than hell like not nothing like that
like there is there is something that
has happened in every one of the stories
you've talked about or I think how is
that possible and they all have their
own unique thing about them that just
seems unreal I'm gonna throw in an
orange vest and mark my position in 30
below so you can see me so you know
where I am cuz I'm the leader because
I'm the leader and uilleann yeah yeah
unreal
that being said World War one no III
don't I don't know that that I don't
know that that is out there the the
complete lack of control that you had as
a individual soldier yeah as a not not
even as a a platoon commander as a
company commander you had no control
over your fate yeah that's that's what I
that's what scares me so much about
World War one it wasn't like hey joko
here's here's here's the situation
here's what we're trying to accomplish
why don't you go figure out the best way
to do it and I go okay you know what
cool I can do this we can we can come up
with some cool tactics we can make some
stuff happen it was hey tomorrow morning
at zero six hundred fourteen thousand of
us are gonna go at zero six hundred and
then guess what's gonna happen at zero
six fifteen another fourteen thousand
yeah and guess what's gonna happen at
zero six thirty another fourteen
thousand and guess what a vast majority
they were gonna be wounded or killed and
that's that so that that to me and and
I'll tell you what they call that the
war to end all wars
I think if
there would have been internet yeah
photographers yeah Instagram Twitter
YouTube that might have been the last
war right that might have been the last
word if you were it's not that if you
saw that as a leader
cuz I'm just talkin I think about I
think about like you're a general and
you're in charge and you organize this
big operation and then you you give the
execute order and then 22,000 men are
killed in the first 24 hours who does
that
yeah who does that now and this is this
is a dichotomy because are there
situations where people have done
operations and are there situations that
warm that it's like hey guess what we
are gonna do this mission and we don't
have a real good chance of coming back
and that's the way it is
yeah and it's a strategic piece of the
mission and does that happen could that
happen absolutely and do people in the
military sign up for that would I sign
up for that if that was what was
required well yeah that's what we signed
up for
but it has a leader like that to be
sitting there looking at 25,000 men and
you gained you know 75 yards of mud and
and you know what you go okay that was
bad we're not gonna do that again no no
you know what you say you know what
we'll do it harder right we'll do it
harder which is which is what makes me
it makes that war to me just absolutely
sickening it's it's sickening it is it
absolutely is and they calculus that
goes into that is something that is
completely disconnected from the value
of human life completely disconnected of
what that impact is and then you you
read this letter and that's 14,000 moms
on that one wave that one time that's
14,000 of these letters and the
disconnect of human life
yeah it's it's and it's actually hard
kind of hard to fathom you talked about
you know
yeah the high-risk operation you know
we're gonna go in
Monteux the worst possible citrus cuz
yeah and you know what we all kind of
secretly would say hey if that opportune
for that you know the high risk but as
as that's just how we do operations all
the time that's just what we do ya know
that's that's uh that's actually a
nightmare yeah
in the other thing with World War one
right like World War two you're looking
at Nazis and you're looking at the
Imperial emissary and you're thinking
we've got real bad guys here
we got legit bad guys that's that's a
factor to write it Germany World War one
it's like yeah we wanted a little extra
land whose that land for you know what I
talked about what you know wouldn't work
with companies and I say so okay CEO
says I you know my frontline troops
aren't doing what they're supposed to do
and it's affecting our bottom line and
you know I say oh we gotta explain to
them why it's important right and so the
CEO goes down and says hey you guys need
to do a better job on the front lines so
that the company can be more profitable
and the front line people are like we
don't care for ya that doesn't mean that
doesn't matter to me yeah I'm making 17
bucks in 17 hour and I got a wife and I
got a kid and I got a basketball game
tonight and I got a mortgage and I got a
house payment
the company being profitable makes no
difference to me whatsoever
yeah so imagine now your World War one
and you're gonna get an extra 14 miles
of land that's the goal to get 14 miles
of land in some country and and it's not
for you it's for like the government
yeah yeah it's absolutely it's atrocious
yeah and and when you're sending US
Marines across the atlantic ocean to get
engaged in that war in like to keep
Germany from encroaching a little bit
too far west
you know France yeah yeah the the why
doesn't you know that doesn't that
doesn't resonate have I have I ever
talked about I do I don't know if I've
talked to uh sir I've ever talked about
the white flour thing they didn't in
Britain the white flour
so if you were like a able-bodied young
man if you were a military age male yeah
and and you weren't wearing a uniform
and you weren't like fighting women
would come up and give you a white flour
it was the mark of shame and the
government started that campaign yeah
the government started that campaign of
hey you see you see someone that's not
in uniform military-age male able bodied
fighting man you go up and give him a
white flower he's a coward I'm prepping
a book right now for the podcast and
actually a couple books but it's a
nightmare because what they're doing is
they're they're executing British
soldiers that have that that desert or
run away or have shell-shocked yeah
they're just dysfunctional they they
can't do it anymore and it's it's awful
some of the stories these guys are
soldiers that have been on the line for
a year and they break they break which
everyone dick weiners talks about people
Brit brave the bravest guys yet they
might break and you got to get him off
the line hacker same thing you got brave
guys sometimes you got to get him off
line World War one we got a British
soldier he's been fighting for a year in
the trenches he's been getting mortared
he's been getting bombed he says I can't
do this anymore okay we're gonna shoot
you at dawn and they did it yeah that's
another thing it's completely insane
yeah we use the analogy a lot we talk
about there's a National Front like hey
your folks are into pushing her folks
too hard it's like it's like driving a
car in the red you rerunning this car in
the red you're running them hard and if
you keep them in the red too long that
car is gonna break that and then jiz
gonna break
now you can you can push to the red a
little bit you can kind of throttle up
and and do that you gotta bring it back
and that's sort of one of the leaders
job is sort of sort of pay attention to
that this is the
like I'm gonna run my car in the red
until my car explodes and then I'm gonna
be mad at the car I'm gonna blame the
car and the the disconnect of that and
we'd like you said that this connect of
the impact of the human being that that
that that's what leaders are supposed to
do that's their job is to and dick
winners had that he talked about the
idea of like hey when when somebody puts
their head in their hands that's the
physical they're literally showing you
hey man um I'm breaking right now and
the willingness to just say go do it
again and then get to the point like I
can't then go we're done with you we
don't have any more use for you anymore
yeah that's hard to comprehend it's hard
to comprehend um but like I said in
prepping these books it's awful to read
them it's awful to read him some of a
lot of the quotes from the soldiers that
were chosen to be the executioner's
right I mean what's that what's that I
remember I started one podcast off for
that was like these soldiers were picked
to go list of this kid had been in the
Army for a couple weeks and he had to go
shoot a deserter that was just one of
his first assignments what the hell yeah
so there's some kind of a some some kind
of an you know do we value human life
more now that's the question I think the
answer if you compare today compared to
World War one the answer is 100% yes
without a doubt 100% yes we do we do in
the military we do and we do everywhere
I think we absolutely do you got a nice
long history of podcasts that are just
sort of soul-crushing yeah you know
you've hit some real homeruns there with
some podcast you're like wow that is
that is hard but you know what the
reason that we hold human life in
greater value now is because of that is
because of those stories is because this
letter I mean there's that that that
small piece of having to understand that
we are here because of where we came
from we are here because of what we did
and what we endured and now that's not
to say we won't go back to do that again
that doesn't mean that we can't end up
back in that place but
those those stories that that legacy of
that just crazy impossible to understand
how you can do that to that many people
and just say that's just how we do
business that's just what we do we have
come a long way and I think we've moved
in the right direction now there is a
piece that when people go to war people
die oh yeah you know that's and we we
can't get to a place or to a point or to
a belief in our society where that is
not acceptable that it's that is not
something we're willing to have happen
or an order for us to be successful that
that is not okay to get to point that
any loss of life or any injury or any
sacrifice is not okay we can't get to
that point so overshooting that is not
good either
I wouldn't use World War one has a
benchmark you know that's just it's not
even close but the reality is is that
that's not just how war is but that's
actually necessary and that's a as a
leader that's a huge burden that's a
huge burden and the burden is to balance
the the responsibility that you have to
do everything to ensure that doesn't
happen to your people knowing full well
knowing full well that it will and I'll
be really dude I'll be really honest
with you I did not when I went to Iraq I
did not really grasp that it might
happen to my guys I just didn't and I'm
I just didn't give it enough thought
that the risk was actually gonna end up
with me and my guys and that Kris was
gonna get killed and I look back on that
as a leader and I'd I should have
thought about that more I should have
prepared for that more and I should have
known what that meant more
and I did and the reality is is that
anybody in this business that goes to
combat in any shape or form has to be
prepared for that and to recognize that
that is what happens in combat and that
your job as a leader is to do everything
you can to prevent it knowing full well
that that is going to happen that's what
happens how long did it take you once
you were on the ground in Ramadi
not long so so the the sledgehammer for
me sir I mean I will never forget the
day I'll never forget in June 20th ever
the sledgehammer for me was the first
day I got there the guy that I was
replacing got in a Humvee hit an ID now
he he was wounded but he broke both of
his legs in a Humvee that I was supposed
to take from him we were supposed to do
the turn over that hump be ended up
obviously not getting that vehicle cuz
it got blown up but it was a major in
the Marine Corps and it was like majors
and major aviator in the Marine Corps
got blown up by an ie D so I I got up to
speed very quickly and that place had an
ability to get you to be aware of the
reality of it very fast so I think I got
there very fast day one something
happened but the anticipation of that
getting there
that was kind of a sledgehammer for me
what about in reading reports when you
were going in so I I we talked about
this last time my best friend was in
Ramadi you know yeah Neil Neil was in
Ramadi in 3rd battalion 7th Marines so
make no mistake Jocko I I objected Lee
understood what was going on I mean I
was aware I knew I was getting myself
into when I asked to go on that fact to
her to Ramadi
but the disconnect was what it meant
it's sort of like the same disconnect
that we were talking about when you read
these books yeah like you're reading
reports but you're if you're not there
mentally well look combat for me was
dropping a bomb in Iraq you know in
Afghanistan was a certainly more
aggressive experience for me you know it
was a
more regular pace there was certainly
some risk involved but you talked about
the first combat experience on this
podcast a lot we've talked about just
the first combat experience as well I
did not really get it until I saw it and
actually in some ways you could say I
didn't get it till I heard it you know
the sounds of combat what it really
sounds like to have a bullet go past
your head so close to you can actually
sort of gauge how close it was to your
head and whether it was closer to the
guy next to you three feet away or
closer to you who is the sniper actually
looking I've had those thoughts I know
you have two so the sights of the sounds
of that it's just it's hard to replicate
and I've actually been envious you've
talked about the training that you did
for your guys at task unit bruiser and
some of the things you did I didn't do a
lot of those things you know and I and I
showed up and like this is no criticism
I throw a hidden anybody this is just
the way it was I got to that that that
unit that I deployed with a showed up in
October I did some training I kind of
really joined the unit in earnest in
like January and I was in Ramadi in
February we kind of you sort of laughed
to me last time I shot my rifle in
training once i cibc o die oriented my
my sights on my rifle
when I got to Ramadi you know and that
that training range they had just on the
outside and made sure my sights were in
good shape before I went out on my first
patrol the next day so in a lot of ways
I was just kind of in over my head with
what that was and then on that
deployment it just grew yeah it's crazy
and it happened so there was you know
that's the sort of the the trial by fire
story I mean it that's what it was for
me but I will say this I got up to speed
quickly in the recognition the reality
and look people were certain we're
getting wounded people getting killed
pretty regularly that you could see like
man that's that's close that's real
that's on the street I've been on that's
in a patrol I've done that's an opiate
I've manned so I I I got to that point
very quickly and the lessons that I had
grown up with as a leader
the way that I I was as a leader I was
able to leverage that they they still
worked leadership and combat it's it's
certainly more dynamic it will certainly
strike more fear in you but the
principles don't change and I was old
enough and mature enough and I had
enough under my belt to say okay I need
to control this I need to control how I
react in this setting and I need to do
what I do and I need to do the things
that I know what I need to do and I was
lucky enough to be able to do that and
keep my you know my wherewithal and not
get overwhelmed by it and I saw guys get
overwhelmed by it here and there it was
a place that could do that to you but I
was able to fall back on leadership
principles how you leading Marines were
you or did you think mentally right the
mental game of being able to detach and
be able to take a step back and as a
fighter pilot did you just say oh this
is what it's like as a fighter pilot
this is what it's like oh I remember
it's like landing on an aircraft carrier
I'm gonna be stressed out when I oh I
need to go over come that did you just
apply the same mechanisms to all right
now I'm gonna be stepping foot on the
battlefield and this is how I need to
apply this same mentality the same
mechanisms I had enough experience of
being scared and controlling the fear
that comes along with things that are
scary that it looked different it
smelled different it sounded different
but the feeling was exactly the same
does that make sense
yeah so that's what I was yeah that's
like I said that's why I saw yeah I'm
imagining that you know even even for us
okay so let's say freefall like you're
going to freefall
well you're jumping out of an airplane
and I I was I thought I would be more
scared the first time I jumped out of an
airplane but I was actually pretty
pumped so that's not a great example but
there's times in the SEAL Teams where
you do something in training where
you're like okay this is a little bit
sketch right yeah a little bit yes and
you know what do you do you do the same
thing you know okay this is what I'm
gonna do
I've practiced it I've rehearsed it I'm
gonna I'm gonna execute this thing and
we're gonna make it happen and you learn
how to do that so when you get in combat
you have a protocol to follow to take
that suite if you're good now you know
we see key people that they they have
the protocol may aren't able to apply it
to the situation yeah
I I never really freaked out when I was
there it the the reality was oh this is
a lot closer to me than I thought it was
gonna be the reality was it hit me
harder than I expected in my preparation
you know wasn't where it needed to be to
be ready for it when I got there I knew
that feeling and I felt that several
times in my career and the response to
it is is it's all the same and one of
the best things about responding to
those situations is that as a leader
you're really busy there's a lot to do
you you've got a lot going on a lot of
decision you have to make a lot of
things you have to be aware of and
that's actually one of the best remedies
for all that and you know it's probably
really tough for someone it really
junior in the organization that may feel
like it doesn't know what's going on
doesn't have a real sense of those
things I was never really bored yeah you
don't have enough time they have a lot
of time now III know the feeling I've
had it I felt that feeling and it's like
man this is a lot different I'm in
humvee I can't see things I'm used to
being able to see my situation awareness
is different how I gather information
all that is different because the
environments different the feeling the
same in the response is the same and
like I said I had the luxury if you want
to call it that I was always busy I was
that stuff going on I had always things
to do whenever I didn't just sit there
and think wow this is terrifying and
scary and I don't know what to do it's
in the aftermath that look back oh man
that was that was crazy you know I
remember I have this very vivid memory
of doing
we called him presents patrols so we
take a couple of Humvees and cruise
around and in this case it was a the
town I was called Tamim is a little town
in Ramadi they're on the south side and
just a nasty place just not a good place
and a presence Patrol is really just you
just waiting to get shot at and we would
weave in and out of the the streets and
you know the buildings are two three
stories high and we pulled up to an
intersection where the second vehicle
and this two vehicle patrol and the
vehicle turns into souza vehicles itself
yes yes we're number two that's good
some the first vehicle makes a
right-hand turn as soon as he turns
right a guy with an RPG I can see him up
you know right in my 12 o'clock position
and it goes over the hood of our vehicle
hits the wall it doesn't detonate but I
think I might have mentioned this before
and I'm just yelling go go go go go
and those are the stories that in the
after when you look back in the a friend
like man that was crazy but at the time
you don't really spend a lot of time
you're saying gears yeah you're like oh
right hey and you're on the radio hey
where's the other vehicle hey this which
is how you you're you're talking you're
communicating you're doing all the
things you're supposed to do so you can
look back on those things and a lot of
times I look back on like man that was
out of control that was nuts or but
during those times even some of those
those terrifying experiences I was just
too busy to really worry about it and I
was making decisions and I think as a
leader that's that's actually good
because I don't want to sit there and
think about all these things that are
scaring me when I just respond to it and
just make a decision and do something
and I actually had a lot of time in my
career where I was I got very
comfortable making decisions and
difficult environments very quickly
that's aviation in a nutshell and so I
think I was able to adapt to that very
quick and that's part of the reason why
I was able to get through that that
deployment the way that I did you know I
had some decompression we talked about
that after after the fact but not a lot
while I was there
did you ever punch out of your aircraft
never rejects no is that just luck yeah
I mean some of its beyond your control
and it's pretty rare it doesn't happen
all that often
yeah but not me Jack you know one of the
things you were taught when you were
talking about you know will you
basically went on a whole comment there
about you know you got a year in a
situation going back to the original
subject here as a leader you're in this
situation where you're gonna take these
guys that you care about and you're
gonna do everything to protect and
you're regardless of how much you want
to protect them there you're gonna put
them in situations where they can get
killed and that that the new book coming
out the first chapter is called the
ultimate dichotomy so what it's called
steel Tumut dichotomy and there's a
reason because that is the ultimate
dichotomy there's no that for a leader
as far as I'm concerned that is the
absolute hardest thing that you have to
deal with as a leader yeah the fact that
you care about these guys it's you're
all you've been taught all you believe
all you think all you you're you're
morals and your values or all of these
for these guys that are doing anything
for you and you'll do anything for them
and you know their families and you know
their kids and it's like yeah guess what
take all that and now you're gonna send
them on missions where there is no doubt
that they can get wounded or they can
get killed you met Marco sat at the
muster we talked about him earlier and
this is a kid that would have done
anything for me to this day he would do
anything for me this is a kid that loves
me he'll love this kid too and that's
that feeling that is very hard to
explain if you haven't gone through it
and it's very hard to describe how
powerful that is at every single day I
threw Marco sand the turn of my Humvee
stuck his head up you know as an armored
Humvee was great but at the end of the
day you know the turret gunner has to do
he's got to get his head up out of the
turret and man that 240 golf or 50 Cal
whatever we had on that on any given day
and stick his head out of that Humvee
every single day and I thought about
that all the time all the time and it is
exactly what you just described this is
someone that would have done anything
for me this is someone that I loved and
would have done anything for and every
day it was get in the turret and let's
go that's what you do yeah and you do
everything you can to prepare them and
everything you can to make sure it
doesn't happen and the last thing you
tell them is hey get up there and we
gotta go we gotta go do this
no just can you even fathom can you even
fathom that that happens and you do it
for months and you do it for months and
you do it for a year and finally he says
you know what I can't do this anymore
and then you said you know what okay
we're pressing charges against you
you're going to court-martial we find
you guilty that's insane and to take it
a step further we're gonna get somebody
else in my unit to pull the trigger
we're gonna get another guy from this
unit from this battalion this fund this
team to follow through with that battle
it's it's not actually no I can't
comprehend that I can't understand that
I can't I can't either
I mean um like I said I'm doing a
podcast about it in the near future yeah
but for the love of God that's a
trajectory it's it's thank God being in
this time period
yeah and and we could talk about this
stuff for days you've talked about it
you just the last podcast with the
Imperial Japanese doing those
experiments we talked about the
dehumanization and look obviously it's
it's grotesque but the dehumanization of
your enemy I understand how that happens
I can I can understand we don't get
there yeah I I can see how people can
get that yeah I can see that and I know
that that I know the seeds that had that
grows and I know that feeling of how
that feeling grows over time of of that
disdain and that dehumanization that I
said I would never have happened to me
and I felt and I know that feeling so I
my point is that well if you've ever
heard me say with our enemy we didn't
really have to dehumanize them because
they dehumanized themselves as we saw
what they did yes or they acted yeah and
what they did to the civilian totally
it's absolutely you you dehumanized
yourselves and yeah and you're gonna
suffer the consequences of that yep and
so that's a bridge in my mind I can
cross I understand that I don't
understand how you can get to a point
where the value of the human life of
your own men is that you just discard
them at the end like oh you're done got
it line them up and that to me is kind
of horrifying because you're not a small
unit I don't have a big unit and I
certainly knew my guys pretty well and
and maybe when you have a you know a
huge unit of a bunch of unnamed people
you don't build strong relationships by
the end of the day they're wearing your
uniform at the end of the day they're
they look sound talk and are just like
you a lot of them come to the same place
as you and that's really difficult to
accept that human beings are capable of
doing that
like I said when it's your enemy or or
it's when it
someone that's different than you you at
least can comprehend that and you see
we've seen that in history but your own
guys that's that's a different level
it's a different time period yep
so going back to or not going back to
you but going forward right you got out
of the Marine Corps I mean obviously we
covered a little bit us on the last
podcast we covered about you know we did
we kind of read the text last time
you're on the podcast of kind of how the
transition you know you got out you came
to an event with life and I and we hung
out and you were thinking yourself yeah
this looks like what I want to do but
there's been more to it than that that
you've kind of briefed me on a little
bit yeah how much time we got yeah that
there is there's a lot more to it
the work that we do is awesome and I
wrote you a letter several months ago
now but I wrote you a letter kind of in
some ways you know somebody's like hey
thank you for bringing the part of this
team at the end and there was you know I
wanted to express some some gratitude
and I did that to everybody to have been
brought into something that is really
incredible and and and I wanted that to
be clear but I also wanted to kind of
explain what I was going through as as
part of the transition and what has hit
me the hardest is not the things that I
expected to happen that have happened
and look some really good things have
happened this is an awesome company we
do great things I get to make an impact
and I love being a part of this and I
saw it so I sort of expected to be able
to do that and be a part of that and see
the impact of that but I didn't give
much thought at the time to how I was
going to impact me and what the impact
of being a part of this would mean from
for my growth and and for myself I think
we just talked about this earlier today
when I get introduced at these events
all the time and they read my bio
sometimes and I hear the words of what
we're doing and everything
and what I've done and and I was at a
point that I can look back and very
easily think that I could have coasted I
could have said hey I died I did some
good work in the Marine Corps I got a
really cool resume and I've kind of got
it figured out I don't have that much
more to learn and I'm gonna kind of I'm
gonna glide I'm gonna kind of go
straight level for a while
and the biggest part of this transition
for me is the recognition that what I
have done to this point and what I
accomplished as a Marine and the things
that I did is a pilot and it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter because if I
cash in now and I check in the box and
I'm done and I Coast from now I'll
define my life by having coasted for the
rest of my life
and I wasn't really prepared for having
to recognize that how much more there is
for me to learn and how much more there
is for me to do and that has been by far
the best and the most humbling part
about this and you got you know me at
this point you know me well enough that
I'm not afraid to admit you know things
that are kind of hard to admit I'm not
afraid that kind of humble myself I'm
not afraid to say well I got that wrong
I didn't see that coming this transition
has been way way more than I thought it
was gonna be and in some ways has
actually put me on my heels a little bit
it's been a reminder that man I'm not
even close to doing the things that I
want to do before I'm done I'm not even
close and it's that's a hard feeling
sometimes it's actually I struggle that
a little bit because a lot of times
people around me tell it tell me I've
done great things and I hear that a lot
and it's great to hear but I'm not even
close man and and and that is something
I struggle with every day and I work at
every day and I have a lot a lot a lot
I don't think that you you didn't get to
where you were without feeling that
right yeah you don't get to you don't
get to be you know the all the things
that you did in your big bio without
saying without without having in the
back your mind like I need to do more
than I need to do better right yeah
that's true that is true but the
magnitude of of it it gets bigger over
time it doesn't get smaller the
magnitude continues to grow this is like
when you start jujitsu and you're like
well you know what you give me a few
weeks like two or three months I'll
probably be tapping this guy out yeah
and then no two weeks into it you're
going oh my god there's a whole nother
thing here yeah that might be one of the
best metaphors for it you know that that
experience look the digits of things
started because on the podcast I was
describing for the last podcast I was
describing flying tea house described it
was just shopping dog fighter you know
like dude that sounds exactly like
jiu-jitsu and that's kind of what
sparked my interest is there a way to
kind of replicate those experiences that
I had that I know I can't do in an
airplane anymore but can I can i
replicate that in some other way and
that was what was intriguing to me and
that was what got me on the path of that
but look I already said this I didn't
think the magnitude of the panic of oh
god I'm running out of time I have so
much more to do was gonna get bigger
over time and that is sort of what like
jiu-jitsu is is and and I again I think
we've had this conversation well I've
made fun of yeah this podcast when you
weren't here of you be you know you sent
me a text like bro I'm this is horrible
like oh what's what's going on you're
like what I I'm never gonna be like
really really really good at you yeah
you know hey man you're whatever you're
46 years old
you know ya get good you know get good
it's all good ya know certainly I think
the message is and the lesson for me is
is a reminder of something I did know
something
throughout my life of that feeling of
the clock is running you're on the clock
right now you don't know when that clock
is gonna end but I'm gonna tell you
around you're on it and every second
that you're not grinding on that clock
you lose it and there's a point where
complacency will try to sneak in the
complacency will try to crawl up and go
dude you've been crushing it look at
what you've done
and that voice can kind of get loud and
it can kind of tell you like dude it's
time to kind of turn the corner and
coast a little bit kind of kind of glide
just a little bit you're good and I
think the best thing that's happened to
me is that exposure to special on front
exposure to the team and exposure to
jiu-jitsu in a way of not like oh maybe
some world champion and it's that bro
the more you know the more you learn the
less you actually know because learning
just means like oh there's more out
there so you go from one to two
but what's available is a hundred to a
thousand and you get to three and a
thousand turns into 10,000 and jiu-jitsu
is infinite and so every time I get to
whatever the next step is the next level
all it really does is is this to
somebody's opening door go oh it's
actually bigger so it's almost like
you're getting worse you know if you do
the math like right now at level four
out of a million you're like it's like
yesterday there was only four moves yes
no today there's 40 boobs they don't
know yeah and the other thing is from
from okay for our dogfighting in an
aircraft right it seems like there would
be some limitation without a doubt okay
we and we haven't we you and I have not
had this conversation but I've had those
thoughts they're absolutely absolutely
as a limit there's only so many things
that you can do yeah and that's actually
not true yeah you know and and in an
aircraft you know just just by
constraints of time I mean you can't you
can't go up and dogfight for four hours
a day every now you do that in Top Gun
first yeah for a few years but the
opponents that you have well I guess
you're going against the other struck
that
that's as good as you're gonna get yeah
but jujitsu you can do that for lo two
years the parallels undeniable the
parallels and you saw that right away
you and I talked about that there's no
question that has been the most
intriguing thing for me is that it's I'm
able to replicate those feelings but the
unlimited nature of how what's out there
if I had a guy in a Hornet that I was
gonna go do BFM with and he was we were
gonna do these this maneuvers and he'd
be like I like to do this when I'm
defensive and it wasn't exactly what
he's supposed to do he was gonna lose
every single time like oh you're not
gonna do the best method in this
situation good I'm gonna savage you like
that yeah there is no this is what works
and everything else is inferior and we
have the geometry we have the math we
have the science the physics and we
actually a Top Gun through a ton of
effort and try to never actually figure
out this is what you need to do here
they say you create the most amount of
closer these are all the things you do
to maximize your aircraft and so if
somebody deviates from that it's just
better for you that's not true yeah
that's not like it's been so broken down
and so studied that there's no
possibility that someone could come up
with something to go oh I came up with
something new no it's not happening nope
when you're a Top Gun I would love to
see somebody to try something new yeah
yeah go for it
yeah yeah do your worst did you come up
with your best game plan because I know
what you need to do in this situation
and if you don't do that you're just
giving me opportunity that's what you're
doing and so there is a level of that in
jiu-jitsu where you know they're all
again put your arms up there's all that
you're gonna give up your back there's
all these things that you can't do but
for instance Jeffy Glover he'll give up
his back and then he's rolling away free
or yeah Dean Lister he's the you're
getting him in a triangle you think and
then you're getting your guard faster
getting smashed so there's there's times
where the things that you don't expect
someone to do they do and it's
problematic yeah and I want to be very
careful I'm I'm so new at this that I
almost should not have
be telling you what I think I know about
this but the glide path to get from
seeing the inside of an f-18 for the
first time to being right at the very
apex of that community six seven years
oh really
yeah about seven years from I'm gonna
introduce you to this airplane yeah I
think you know you know how to fly but
now I'm gonna introduce you to a combat
aircraft for the first time in your life
a real combat machine you're gonna get
in that thing I got that in 1998 first
time I set foot in an f-18 I got to Top
Gun
in 2000 2002 I left in 2005 so I would
say I was kind of at my apex in 2005 so
from 98 205 that's how long it took me
to be at the top of that world am I
gonna be can you imagine like the best
guys in jiu-jitsu the guys that have
been doing it for five to six years yeah
well they're well what you have to do is
you there are some anomalies out there
yeah there's guys that are incredible
lean the credible natural athletes and
also you'd have to take someone and say
okay this is your job cuz that was yeah
yeah that's a big piece hey this is your
job and that happens some kids get into
jujitsu and they're like oh I'm gonna
sleep on the mat all I'm gonna do is
train BJ Penn got his black belt and did
well did he win the worlds and after
three years I don't know I don't think
so but you know in three years ago his
backbone he was a legit black belt
someone was asking on social media the
other day hey is this guy legit he seems
to have gotten his black belt got his
black belt from Danaher in a short
period of time
oh you mean the judo Olympian he might
have some skills yeah he might be able
to get up there pretty quick yeah yes
for that answer yes that dude is legit
you can get your black belt you can get
your back black belt pretty quickly if
you have a bunch of natural talent maybe
you have some kind of base wrestling
judo or something like that
and then you make it your job yeah you
can get your you can get really good
really fast yeah but yeah basically if
your mind is like addicted to it in one
way or another and then you have some
prerequisite like you know the Geo and
yeah
the yeah the Martinez brothers they had
breakdancing did a lot of the same stuff
you know and that kind of went along
with their styling I would go so far as
to say this is this is a guess I would
go so far as to say that most people
that have their black belt in jujitsu
were in the obsessed mode at some point
in their life make sense that's what I'm
gonna say sure I cannot disagree with
that right
have you ever known someone that's a
black belt that that was not at least
for a period of three years was just
that's all I thought about I don't know
if any no yeah they they were just into
jiu-jitsu real article yeah and then
maybe they grew out of a little bit or
some whatever yeah some people just keep
training hard that's how it is one of
the things that you did and this is
gonna hate to cycle back to the podcast
again but I'm gonna do it real quick I
had a had a note about it and it's
something that you and I have talked
about several times when Tom Fife came
on the podcast Purple Heart you know
served in World War two Korea Vietnam
Purple Heart World War two Korea Vietnam
battalion commander in world war in
Vietnam company commander in Korea and I
think tank platoon commander in order to
tank platoon commander in World War two
so if that's your resume what sir I'm
sorry engineer yeah that's and so so
there's his resume but it was really
interesting so when he came on the
podcast and we were talking about you
know leadership and stuff like that and
he gives this answer of yeah we were
talking around the subject of you know
how do you get someone how do you know
how do you get your people to listen to
you and he says hey you tell him to do
it and they do it and I remember you and
I talked and afterwards it was like man
that was not a that was not a Jocko
answer of like hey you know they listen
you gotta build a relationship with
people you gotta you gotta get their
trust you gotta earn their respect you
gotta you gotta treat them how you want
to be treated and then when if you
explain to them why the mission is
important and they but
even the mission and they know that
you're gonna back them up then they're
gonna back you up when you need that but
do something like I got this whole thing
right yeah this is big problem it's this
big dance you got to go through as a
leader and and I think to myself yeah
I've got this figured out and so you
guys know I tell people to do it like
man that's kind of it's kind of a bummer
and think of what I'm gonna tell echo to
edit that out right just kidding but
then this is the cool part it was then
he he continued to talk about it
and he gave just the most perfect answer
of the things that everything that we
say all the time everything that we talk
about national on front everything that
I talk about in this podcast he gave it
all yeah he really just did it in
reverse order of conversations we have
we explained sometimes that in really
challenging environments sometimes you
got it to say hey go make this happen
and you got to have your people say
Roger that and they go make it happen
you got to be able to do that sometimes
but the only way for that to work in
those really demanding difficult
challenging environments is to go way
back before and build all those
relationships and create all that trust
and do all those things so when people
go they've just said go make this happen
or go make it happen we'll ask questions
later he just went to that part because
I almost set it up for that because the
question I was asking him was how do you
get a guy to jump out of your tank under
fire to fix the turret in his mind
that's there like there's rounds hitting
the tank yeah ping ping ping ping ping
and that the tank track falls off and
someone's got to get out there and exit
and he goes to the junior guy and he's
like you gotta get out there and fix it
and so it was he just did that whole
thing in Reverse already went to that
part and then and I remember thinking
like and that's kind of a bummer answer
it really wasn't expecting that it was
like you just tell him what to do yeah
and why didn't that work for me yeah I
might have to change the way yeah so
when he started to go and I remember
that feeling of like Oh II and now he's
starting to explain it I looked at you a
couple I was like yeah
he did the whole thing and he he he
speaks very plain language too and he
just sort of distilled it all down as
like you have to take care of your
people you have to treat your people
well and if you do they will do the same
for you and if you don't guess what when
you say jump out of the tank under fire
they're gonna say no yeah that was the
best when he actually came all the way
back around and said if you just think
you're just gonna tell someone to get
out of my tank under fire and they don't
believe in what's going on and they
don't trust you and you haven't taken
care of them they're not going anywhere
yeah every time I hear all the people
you've had on the podcast I know the
stories are different but they're all
saying the same thing they're all saying
the same thing in their own little
nuanced way there are little experience
but it's always the same thing and that
was of all over my favour because I got
to know Tom before the podcast and we
got to talk quite a bit and I got to
spend time with him before we went live
on that recording so I enjoyed that one
the most
but it's everybody's saying the same
thing yeah MOOC made a huge point about
that well about caring about your people
yeah you got to care about your people
again these are guys that were do that
relieving draftees yeah Vietnam draft
these and I went off of this event we're
at the other day is there any more
hostile work force in in it okay moving
on the history of the world but is it
this is right up there you've got guys
that have been because it's you know if
you're in World War two and you get
drafted guess what the country's behind
the war its World War two you're gonna
be a hero you believe you're fighting
against Nazis or Imperial Japanese that
are evil humans and you're on board for
the big win we get that that's what
happens Korea like not quite so clear
but guess what we still even remember
World War two so guess what we're gonna
go get in the game yeah Vietnam they
straight-up don't believe in the war
they just straight-up don't believe in
the war they're there against their will
under threat of prison they show up
there and these are the people you're in
charge of and this is the answer I give
all the time now for remote would be
ask me about malleolus people are like
huh you don't we got Millennials they
got a bad attitude
oh really oh really
the Millennials have a bad attitude
compare that to a drafted Vietnam
soldier and here's the thing that I
realized because and when I pulled it
when I started going through hack again
how about facing it and I started
reading that I realized that you got to
change your perspective as a leader it's
not just it's not just hey cuz we
simplified it like well if you're
Millennials aren't doing what you want
it's your fault that's that's a
simplification of it because what you
really got to do is you got to shift
your mindset a little bit and say like
what wait a second how do I take
advantage of that's what Hackworth was
doing hackworth was saying wait a second
how do I take advantage of these guys
guess what they're gonna question me if
I do something wrong they're gonna
report things that aren't done correctly
they're gonna say no if I plan something
stupid is that a bad thing let me think
about it actually no that's actually not
a bad thing
so if you've got a millennial that's
like hey if I don't like the leadership
here I'm leaving the company guess what
let's get that person some good
leadership you got a millennial that
says hey if I don't understand why we're
doing what we're doing I don't I don't
care I'm not gonna do it okay well let's
explain to that person why do they have
a full understanding of what it is we're
trying to get done
you shift your your mindset a little bit
about the whole deal and you end up in a
much better position but it's a
perspective shift yeah you it's the same
thing we always say if it's not just
take ownership of it so it's if you if
you say oh my Millennials aren't doing
what I need to do that's my fault
that doesn't make them to start doing
what you need them to do you actually
have to make changes in your leadership
style to adapt to this attitude that's
coming your way
and at the end of the day if you do that
you'll have someone that's smart that's
motivated that will get on board with
the program and will do a great job yeah
just like a draft just like a draftee
and when when we see it in in leaders
all the time they present it like ah you
can't leave these people this is
unsolvable problem it is a problem at
the end where we're going down
Hill at supersonic speeds and when you
do what you just said and trying to
change that perspective and then put it
in comparison to the story of the
draftees they're almost a little
embarrassed like no yeah yeah that's one
of those answers when I give that answer
I I I have to soften it a little bit
like a you these guys were taking I
don't I don't throw this in their face
of like hey these guys were taking
draftees that didn't even believe in the
war and we're gonna get killed
yeah yeah like hey you're asking someone
to stay late on a Tuesday night yeah
that's what you're asking for yes they
were asking them to patrol through a
mine ridden jungle right
not to mention this person is actually
interviewed or your company applied for
a job wants to be there yeah there's a
clear difference in generation something
to think about but nobody force this
person to join your team yeah and you
see that in the when the recognition
hits you can see it of like oh yeah no
you're right
this actually is a very solvable problem
it just takes some work on my part yeah
and I mean I that's true with everything
yeah we got I mean we obviously we have
all kinds of companies out there that we
work with now and their workforce is now
becoming all Millennials I mean their
frontline people right now at a company
the frontline people are all Millennials
and so if you don't figure this out oh
who are you gonna hire yeah who are you
gonna hire I mean it's like being in
Vietnam you you were gonna have draftees
if you don't figure that out and and
that's the other thing as you hear the
bad leaders from Vietnam that was that
will say all the draftees were horrible
I couldn't work with them they would you
know they do want to do their job well
maybe you should look in the mirror a
little bit yeah and that the the best
part about that is when we asked same
thing with Tom Fife yeah cuz he's like
that's all that's all we ever had yeah
no that's
that was our military back then when I
was in when he was in the army
it was like I didn't I couldn't tell you
who was a draftee you know it wasn't I
didn't I didn't know the difference they
I there
people yeah they're human beings yeah
and I treated him like that and so the
just the idea that you would segregate
those to the draftees and the and and
the volunteer military was immediate
indication of what kind of leader you
had yeah and these guys are like I don't
first let understand the question all we
had was draftees at the time we every
buddy was being drafted in a second
didn't matter to me they didn't care I
didn't care we had a mission to do I
explained them the impact in the
importance of the mission I told them
their role in that mission and what
would happen if they did or didn't do it
I cared about them and we just did it
and that's my favorite part about Tom
five is he's just a plain spoken guy he
doesn't have this really flowering
articulate language he's like oh yeah I
know I treated my people really well and
when I asked him to do stuff they did it
that's kind of that's kind of it that's
a pretty awesome leadership yeah advice
it is true your people really well and
when a time comes that you need use
something that they need to do something
for you they're gonna do they're gonna
do it take care of your people and your
people are gonna take care of you yeah
we said it about a year take your gear
yeah same thing
take care of your people how about how
about we start with that one and then
your people are gonna take care of you
too
yeah we I think we forget those less
than sometimes you know we like it which
is a human capital it's like no they're
their people they're just people
it's just treat him like people see him
like you treat anybody else and you know
some of those fundamental lessons you
know across leadership I think in a lot
of ways I was lucky to see that modeled
early in my career and I think a lot of
times we end up on the path of who were
following on day one and they can take
you down the wrong road if you've got
the wrong people but when you see it in
other people and they treat you that way
and that feeling of oh this guy this guy
really cares about me this guy really is
invested in me being successful in me
having a good good life and a good
career it's it's not hard to recognize
like oh that that's how that's what I
should do yeah and the exact opposite is
true and like when the people and I work
for people that I despised and I
despised because that how they treated
me how they treated other people and
just very evident like just don't be
like that yeah it doesn't work I'll be
in a group of leaders you know we're
doing working with
I've done this many times where I'll set
it up with hey who here has had someone
in your life as that would that that was
in charge of you that invested in you
and took care you raise your hand and
everyone raises their hand and or 99% of
people raise their hand if not 100
percent of people raised here because
that's you know usually we're talking
leaders in the company and so the
leaders have made progress somehow and
they've made progress because someone at
some point taught them and took them
under their wing and cared about them
and yes I say who who's had someone that
cared about them invested than them and
took care of them
took care of you and serve them raises
their hand and how'd that feel and
everyone says yeah it felt awesome but
what would you do for that leader I'd do
anything for him why don't you be that
leader then why don't you be that leader
and take care of those people properly
and you'll end up with a team they'll do
anything for you not for selfish reasons
because they'll see right through that
you you've got to be doing it for the
team when you want the team to do well
then they'll do anything for you yeah I
think that's a really important lesson
for any leader out there for leadership
in general is how obvious what you're
doing is to other people and whatever
thing you're trying to hide or whatever
thing you're trying to cover up or
something you're trying that's what he
sees everybody sees it yeah everybody
sees right through it and you know we
ask the same question as okay what would
you want your subordinates to do to you
come up and say it's not my fault I
didn't have anything and you this isn't
this isn't my fault I couldn't anything
about it you didn't set me up to win or
would you like someone to walk him say
hey boss I screwed this up there's a
couple things I could have done
differently here's what I learned and
you know what I'm gonna do this next
time I'm gonna get this right and I'm
gonna fix this
and you said those two so really obvious
two different scenarios and asking later
what would you like to have from your
subordinates a hundred percent of the
people gonna go I want the guy that
comes in and says hey is my fault I'm
gonna fix their zone is super obvious
and then the very nice question is why
aren't you doing that with your boss why
do you not think that your boss is
having the same feeling as you would
have with your subordinates and that
recognition of everybody sees exactly
what you're doing
that's uncomfortable for people yeah the
uncomfortable part is it's hard for
people I guess I guess we think that if
you're my boss I think you're not as
smart as me and I think well he's just
gonna blame me when I come in and say
it's my fault you're gonna go yeah I
know that's why I'm fiery yeah music
yeah people are smarter than that and
and no one wants to hear excuses yeah no
one wants to hear excuses ya think you
know what sometimes people screw things
up so bad that they're gonna get fired
I'm just gonna say that like and guess
what if you're going to make excuses
guess what you're gonna get ya
you're gonna take what ever limited
chance of maybe salvaging that at the
last second of like hey boss hang on let
me just if you do that you're just
guaranteeing the appium life talks about
that when he was the XO at a SEAL team
and he says you know he'd get a guy that
was something's going wrong in a platoon
and a guy would come in and say you know
it's not my fault my Chiefs no good or
my LPO doesn't know what he's doing it's
like okay you're fired yeah and the next
that comes in is to say I'm not doing a
good job as a leader here's the things
I'm gonna change like okay yeah well
let's keep working on it let me know if
you have any questions let me know if I
can help you out let's get you the
support you need yeah that's that's a
no-brainer ownership duh
yeah sorry we would we would have board
sometimes for pilots you know
performance boards and and we would
review a lot of material and a lot of
times you you'd have to fire somebody
I mean don't like doing it but in
aviation you it's a lot of times as
they're hold it's the dream week same
thing with the teams like the dream
about this as a kid and you know that
you are ending their life's true dream
crusher
yeah dream crusher you you're gonna
you're gonna do that not to mention
paycheck gone yeah well like four
officers in the SEAL Teams a lot of
times it or retirement or whatever it's
it's a bad situation yeah it's it's
massive impact it's a huge deal to do
that and you take that very seriously
when you're in a position when you're
gonna you're gonna be one of the
deciding factors in whether that person
stays or goes any time you get to that
point where your mind like hey the best
thing is to get rid of this guy and if
you bring him in for this or that final
interview that final interaction the
guarantee wait is
the guarantee way to ensure what they've
already kind of concluded because that's
why they're bringing in in the first
place is to not take any responsibility
it's it not taking any toner that is
100% good now it doesn't mean that you
might just not be able to you might not
have the technical skills at the
capability sometimes you're gonna get
fired and sometimes your mistake is so
egregious and does so much damage yeah
you gotta go you're gonna get fired
you're gonna get fired but even then the
the best thing you can do the best thing
you can do is to take ownership of all
that and be like hey boss I understand
I'm sorry or you can go the other route
and you can start to throw everybody
under the bus and you know what this is
what's interesting there are some people
and I've talked to many of them over the
years many of them they don't make that
connection they literally don't make
that connection they don't make the
connection they're looking at their boss
and they're saying hey this wasn't my
fault it was my whoever it was my
subordinate leader it was the
maintenance guy it was this it was that
they literally don't make the connection
that if you're in charge of something
order you're responsible for something
and it goes wrong you're responsible for
it yeah and they cannot make that
connection you feel like you're you you
just I I would watch when we would have
a bad seal platoon going through my
training and I bring in a platoon
commander or platoon chief and they
would literally like like an assault
chief so the guy is in charge of the
assault he's in charge of the assault
and it's like hey all your men went to
the wrong target what happened well it
was briefed wrong well it was this well
we marked the target wasn't marked
correctly the battle maps I mean
literally just you could come up with 20
excuses and you know what they're all
day all make sense they're like hey
someone made someone put the wrong
number on the brief and and everyone
heard the wrong number and they looked
at their battle map and I went to that
building ok that's what happened whose
fault is it it's not the guy that made
the battle map you're in charge you're
in charge of the
all team you're in charge of the assault
team that this is this is your fault and
it would I would sometimes I would just
actually I would hardly ever say this
was your fault
I would milk I wouldn't try and milk it
out of them I would be like so well I
mean but still like who is in charge of
the assault if only we had a guy in
charge of that yes well you know I mean
the Evo chief you know you can't expect
it look guided to be confirming that
every single guy knows where the target
is really okay okay so you're not
responsible for getting the men to the
target as the you're not responsible for
the assault as the assault chief is what
America so it's really horrible when you
see that someone can't make the
connection and what and and this is this
is another cool thing like on social
media I see this a lot guys will hit me
up girls will hit me up something went
wrong with a client I stepped in I took
ownership they thanked me problem solved
got it squared away I can't people are
surprised people are surprised that it
works people are surprised that it works
and again just to make sure everybody
knows that that alone doesn't work you
still have to problem solve the problem
that you caused with the client right
right
you you you gave them what they needed
late or it's gonna be late and now you
say it's my fault that doesn't mean that
you don't need to get it to him ASAP and
make up some corrective measures and
lower the price do something so that it
makes up for the problem but the worst
thing you can say is well you didn't
specify exactly what you wanted in the
order and therefore we could get you
what you wanted on time okay we're never
coming back for business skin and were
angry this whole time and I'm gonna
short you money when we pay you in
anyways if I pay you at all yeah let's
make it let's make it the customers and
the clients fault let's do that and it
gets back to something you said earlier
about the the conversation about the
Millennials is just for a minute
detach just take a step back real quick
and just put yourself in their position
what do they want to hear what do they
want to hear this client that things
went sideways that what they needed from
you didn't happen they didn't get it
delivered on time it didn't work the way
it's supposed to work or worse you gave
it to something and it created a problem
for
our customers down the line what do they
want to hear from you right now you are
them go and the allergy that should come
from hearing and excuses the allergic
reaction hearing someone tell you it's
their fault or or it's not it's not
their fault it's somebody else's fault a
hundred out of a hundred times
you should understand and the point is
that it's that's still hard to do it's
still hard and that bridge is is hard to
cross and reading the book isn't enough
it it sets the table and exposed you to
it but I think it comes I with
everything you you have to get inside it
you have to live it and but the thing of
it is is the first time you do it the
first time you do it because it works
every single time
once someone once you get to that
tipping point once the the domino falls
I think it's then it's like magic then
it's just things are just happen on
their own and all your people go no no
no no this is this is definitely what
we're gonna do here we're gonna tell
them exactly what we did wrong how we're
gonna solve a problem we're gonna do to
fix it and to make sure it doesn't
happen again and it de-escalates
the client is like oh man I was really
hoping we could fight and argue and
you're not letting me do that now
because what you're saying is everything
I actually really need to hear and I'm
forced to say okay let's go solve this
problem and when you see it from the
inside out and start to do it that
tipping point it happens quick it just
takes a lot of time to get there and
there's so much resistance that human
nature resistance to or there there's no
way I'm taking the blame for this I've
actually got a bunch of good reasons
that I can give you a why it's not
really my fault and I'm gonna kind of
sound like hey boss you know those guys
aren't they're not they're not the best
guys you know that's not the best team
here's here's a here's a let's call it a
drill or or a coaching I'll call it that
a coaching when the next time you get
into a situation and you write down or
you techniques the excuses and the
reasons that you come up with look at
them and then figure out how they were
how those things were actually your
fault and/or how you could have
prevented them
because a lot of times it's like here's
here's here's one hey boss we didn't get
the mission accomplished because the
weather rolled in and we couldn't launch
on the mission that's that's the problem
now we all know that we don't control
the weather so when you will you write
the problem down we failed the mission
because we didn't control the weather we
can't control the weather that's why we
failed the mission that's my excuse
that's a that's a logical reason there's
that's that's a that's a legitimate
excuse but don't use it what you do is
you say what could I have done to have
controlled the weather okay okay wait I
can't control the weather what could I
have done I could have come up with a
contingency plan I could have come up we
could have staged in a better place so
then you go to the boss and you say look
boss here's what happened the weather
went south really bad that was a problem
but it's a problem that I should have
done a better job taking care of what I
should have done was I should have had a
contingency plan
I should have staged closer to the
target area that I could have taken
vehicles instead of helicopters that's
my fault
and from now on I will absolutely have a
secondary plan this won't happen again
we can't control the weather but we can
control how we plan and how we execute
and this won't happen again there you go
so you take the most outrageous thing
that you know you can't control you
figure out a way to control it and you
take ownership of that thing and it is
gonna fit it's gonna make your life so
much better and by the way the next time
you have a mission and you plan that
contingency and you actually execute and
implement what you said you're gonna do
guess what you will accomplish the
mission there's a whole part of
ownership that preempts the problem if
you've got someone that knows if I know
that I can make an excuse if I know that
I can make an excuse then guess what I'm
not gonna set things up properly if I
don't set things up properly mmm more
often or more often than the other way I
will fail to execute what I'm supposed
to execute if you have an excuse right
same same thing with you as an
individual human being if you as an
individual human being if you got some
excuse
that you can throw out there that you
can say I had no control over that
then you know what you say okay what are
my contingency plans what could I have
planned differently let's eliminate
those excuses take ownership of your
freaking life yeah and in that situation
too when you're talking about this this
example of the weather and if you as a
leader actually accept the excuse like
hey boss that storm rolled in and just
crushed us and you're like yeah yeah
yeah out of your control there's no way
you coulda solve for this problem it's
unsolvable what if you just guaranteed
will happen every single time the
weather rolls in you set that in stone
it will never be different the weather
will crush you every single time or you
could ago I don't know look at your
weather app and go we got to go six
hours early in stage and we're gonna
walk in and it works both ways that that
and if you accept those excuses you're
now giving that's a free pass for here
or not the weather is actually something
we can't control so that was now
something that is okay and why we fail
yeah it's I understand that it's hard I
know that feeling and that but when you
see it get to the other side and you see
people do it like don't so that was sort
of like a turning point for me mentally
cuz as I as I grew up and I said to
myself you know well uh yeah I I
understood that I needed to take
responsibility for what was happening
but the turning point for me came when I
realized that no matter what happened if
I'm the guy in charge if I'm the guy in
charge we need to get this thing done
that's the way it is and when you when
you have that thought in your brain the
preparation you do is so much more solid
because there's no way out yeah there's
no way out so you gotta execute when
when leaders see the world like that
when they see it that way
they just work until the problem gets
solved they just do everything they need
to do until they find a way to fix the
problem to solve it and when they don't
think like that they they're there are
outlets that are off ramps to be like I
can't do it can't do it can't do it
can't do it
and we use it we call that the excuse
matrix that's the water here comes the
excuse matrix yeah and and and then the
other part that you gotta remember is
this doesn't mean this doesn't mean that
I'm gonna bang my head up against the
wall 47 times yeah to accomplish the
mission this like Oh guess what the part
part of this is hey I didn't plan it
well I made some mistakes
I didn't calculate correctly and now we
are not gonna get this done and that's
the way it is and so I'm not saying you
continue to beat your head against the
wall 47 47 is the limit don't do 48 when
you've done 48 you've gone too far
you're not gonna get through the wall
yeah trust me if you can get through the
wall it'll get through by the
forty-seventh head but after that it's
not happening so you got to take a
little you got to look for the alternate
route yeah so there's a difference
there's a difference between we're gonna
get this done no matter what and we're
gonna get this done no matter what these
someone's gonna back off yeah sometimes
you get a reattach that's notice yeah
sometimes you got to reassess your plan
and somebody you gotta go a different
direction and when it all costs doesn't
mean I'm gonna charge that elevated
machine-gun nests through open ground it
wave after wave after wave it means
you're gonna do something else
it doesn't mean are gonna abandon the
attack in that position but you might
actually do it a different way and it
may be like my plan sucked here's all
the things that I learn about my stupid
plan
anybody got else maybe I can get some
help he doesn't I've seen this before
this what we did that's a good idea
let's do that plant and you know we
again we could talk about this for a
long time but I think that that natural
tendency to be exposed as as someone who
doesn't know something to be exposed as
someone who doesn't have all the answers
to expose as a leader who doesn't know
everything I'm gonna let you know a
little secret everybody already knows
that everybody knows that you don't know
everything and if you try to act like
you do it will make it 10 times worse
than just saying I actually don't know
what to do here or
made a mistake here when you make a
mistake everybody knows it your
subordinates know it your peers know
what your bosses know it and the worst
thing you can do is to tell them that
you didn't that's why being insecure in
your leadership capabilities is a
downward spiral because the more
insecure you are the more you try and
manipulate them and everything and keep
everything under your wraps and do
everything your way and that's how it is
so when you're insecure as a leader and
that's another that's another thing that
takes a little bit of a leap of faith
that's another like progression that I
personally made I personally made it not
oh I don't care I can't remember when
but when I was like you know what it's
okay it's okay
I'm not gonna be I'm not the best in the
world and everybody knows that and the
more I try and act like that the more
obvious that's gonna be and the minute
you say that the minute you recognize
that people are going hmm
okay he might not be the best but at
least he knows that as opposed to he's
not the best and he thinks he is that's
a nightmare yeah what's the work for
that guy and the best part about what
you just said is that that's something
we all had to learn that's something we
all had to figure out at some point in
our life none of us were born like oh no
I knew all this at birth it's from these
giant errors that we've made or giant
mistakes with these giant realizations
like I've been doing it wrong yeah and
everybody has to figure that out and
then and that right there that is one of
the most gratifying things about what we
do now is that this gap that we talked
about earlier this little gap between
like how do you read something you read
something and then how do you get that
thing out of it how do you extract that
vital piece of information that's in
there how do you do that how do you tell
look it looks like when you're kidding
you don't listen to your parents right
you just how do you get that he'd close
that gap and what's awesome about what
we do now is that we get to close that
gap of people we get I mean I see it on
a daily basis on a daily basis with the
leaders that we work with
you get to see their eyes open up and
you go boom they get it now everything
we just talked about which you know
which we had to learn over time and
extrapolate from our experiences and
then on top of that go through horrible
situations where we failed as leaders
and we've figured out a way to say look
here it is
here's how it works and as see people's
eyes open up and then to see the
performance that's the best to see the
performance go through the roof as the
leader and then of course when the
leader starts doing well then the
leaders start doing well and when all
the leaders start doing well guess what
now we have a winning team yeah to
emphasize what you said that eyes
opening that's a literal thing like it's
not a metaphor you look at them and when
you finally get it to click when you
spin it their eyes actually open up and
they sit up straight and they kind of
sit back a little bit and there is a
moment a physical moment you recognize
that they got it and when you see that
and you can actually set an audience
when you when you when you're when
you're talking to a group like maybe
multiple leaders on the team and you're
around a conference table and you're
interacting and you bring up a
particular example they're dealing with
you lay out the different possible
scenarios and the one that is obviously
the right one and they go oh oh my god
when they get that that feeling is
unbelievable it's the best part about
this is when they get it but you
literally see that happen and that is
awesome and that's that for me so went
out my last three years when I was and
the team is also working running the
training for the West Coast SEAL Teams
and I got to see that I got to see that
with these young leaders and just our
it's it's in my head right I got I gotta
tell the story there's a young kid who I
know who he's an awesome guy and I
didn't really know him that well at the
time but he was kind of like a pipe
hitter and a platoon and there's total
mayhem going on total chaos going on and
I just like go over to him and the kids
you know his platoon commander was
simulated dead and ba ba ba ba ba and
doun chief was simulated an LPO wasn't
making a call in this total chaos man
when I walk over to him I'm like hey man
and he's like yeah and and I go hey man
are you gonna do something about this
right here and and that was all he
needed to hear all he needed to hear was
like that guy that was in charge of all
this training was telling me like was
asking me a question he was questioning
me and saying are you gonna do something
about this his eyes opened up and he
said oh hell yes I am and boom he starts
snapped up started making calls and the
whole the whole paradigm in the
situation completely changed because he
he stepped up and led and so I got to
see that then and I get to see it now so
that's a cool thing yeah it is and the
stories about my experience the top
gunner are identical and when when you
go to missions and they suck and you get
savaged and it's just terrible guys come
back and and they're miserable losing
sucks man it sucks when you have this
huge plan you go out there and you get
savaged it sucks and then when you go
through this whole thing and there's
that recognition and they change the way
they breathe they change the way they
train they changed the way they do
things with their guys and they go out
and they come back and when you dominate
that feeling you're coming back from a
flight and you just dominated that's a
really good feeling and so when when
they do this and they start winning like
you just described you got that team
then they start winning dude then then
then they are then they're thoroughbreds
they're running on your dad and you get
as a leader get to back off like I'm
just gonna watch them go dominate that
feeling of being successful when you
implement these things as a leader
that's the best feeling in the world and
when you see that on from your juniors
Warren's went from your subordinate or
your team and you see them go do that
there is nothing better than yeah and
then you get what we get to see we see I
used to get to see it I see open you get
to see it start to take hold yeah and
but echo you've talked about this where
I'm like where you you know what I'm
doing like with you you know what I'm
doing you sat here through hundreds of
hours of me talking about how I'm gonna
treat someone on my team yes and you're
like you know what I'm doing and it
still works
and what's cool is when when you know
what the person is doing when you know
what you your leaders doing and it still
works
then you go you know what I'm gonna do
it too and that's how it spreads
throughout these ones rights yeah cuz
okay so let's say I make a mistake or
something like that and you say hey it's
you know I should have done this little
better right so it's like obvious like
uh that's that has never been your job
now that you know since whatever
whatever that may be right
so obviously I'm like I know what you're
doing you're so we can get the problem
stuff I get it but to me what I felt was
not what you're doing but what you're
not doing you're not telling me hey
what's up with this you know hey why did
you make that you're not you're not
attacking me so so I have to be
defensive you know you're not doing that
so not defense if I see what you're
doing the whole thing but okay alright
and you want to do is get it done
whatever the thing is I think we all
want to even like with your wife that's
a that's a huge one so the you guys
always talking in context of business
and the boss and the subordinates
whatever same exact thing with your wife
same thing even though it feels like
counterintuitive you know you're you're
you you had all this stuff to do that
you're doing for her by the way and you
didn't take out the trash I don't know
I'm not saying that happened to me not
saying it didn't happen to me but you
didn't take out the trash meanwhile you
did literally from the moment you woke
up to that moment you got it you know
accused or whatever um you did stuff for
her right you could have done that
hypothetically you hurt her saying hey
you know you you didn't take out the
trash all those feelings in your mind in
your heart is - it's not to be like
you're right I should have done that
it's not to say that let's just say the
opposite yeah that's like how did all
this other stuff for you
where it's overwhelming overwhelming
like I will not and cannot bring myself
to say you're right you're right about
that
but if you can manage to do that you'd
be baffled how easy how good it works it
works yeah but yeah it's it's what
you're not doing
I think like if you know like I see what
you're doing I see you're doing they're
using your little chocolate tricks all
this stuff that's not the influential
part the influential part is what you're
not doing no it's so funny now cuz
everyone I deal with now every single
person that I deal with on any level on
any on any depth at all they all know
all my little tricks as you call them
they all know every every person I'm
involved with knows them all you know
and it's likely of it yeah cool I'll go
even one further with this guy he'll go
he'll it's almost like he'll double do
it to the point where it's a joke
insulting you and you think it's funny
yet you're still not a vet so he'll be
like I don't know whatever let's say I
didn't press record on the thing forgot
we'll just say never done that before
may or may not have ever done that
before but he'll be like hey you're
right you know I should I should have
double and triple-check that thing you
know I mean it's way over there but I
still totally couldn't you know so
obvious he's throwing it in your face
you know that it's not his fault but
he's like going through the motions
almost like like kind of condescending
you know but it's so funny because
that's the rule so it's like he's
blaming you but he's not really
officially blaming you but it still
works yeah meanwhile yeah the whole
recording is trashed by the way cuz it
didn't even happen but yeah you're not
defensive because it's just you know
it's like well and I don't say this the
reason why it works quote unquote the
reason it works is they no reason it
works with the people that I deal with
in my life for my family took my
business partners across the board the
reason that it works is because I'm not
doing it for me that's the big
difference so if you're out there and
you're thinking oh cool I'm gonna learn
these tactics so I can I can get further
in my life and I can get things out of
the world it's like no it's not gonna
work out well for you yeah
on the surface cuz I'm gonna tell you
what you got to take that one step
further because guess what if this is
the this is the amazing thing if what
you're doing is your focus on taking
care of the team taking care of your
people doing the right thing for the
right reasons
and you're and you think to yourself so
if you're listening this right now going
well I really want to I really want to
get ahead and Jocko just said I'm not
gonna get ahead if I if I put myself to
get ahead then it's not gonna work so
this isn't for me here's that here's the
dichotomy in this thing and it's a huge
dichotomy if you're there and you're in
a leadership position or you're just in
a position you're in relationship
whatever and you're doing things for the
team you're trying to take care of the
others you're putting other people above
you in the end you're going to win and
you're gonna win way bigger than you
could if you were calling and scratching
and ripping things and bringing them
back to yourself the end that person
that thinks that thinks that they're
doing the right thing or things that
they're doing something good for
themselves but what they're really doing
is taking things from other people that
person they might get a couple of
tactical victories along the way but in
the end the person that puts everyone
else first is going to win they are
going to win so it's it's kind of
hypocritical because it's like in the
one hand it's like no I don't care about
myself I'm not trying to improve I'm not
trying to try to improve my station in
life but by doing that you will improve
your station in life and you will
improve your station in life beyond
anything that you could have done if
your goal was to improve your station in
life that's good stuff right there yes
sir it is take note of that one yeah
any other major topics that you want to
bring up tonight
it works especially with your wife not
also with your wife
but especially with your wife yeah and
so it should just be habit that anytime
she says he didn't do this it actually
she's right you didn't yeah and just be
like you're right I didn't yeah I have
learned that lesson yeah a few times
yeah and again this is gonna sound
obvious but it's one of those things you
gotta kind of consciously remember
especially if you're with your wife with
someone you're with every day or really
really often the part yeah you take you
take ownership you know you take
responsibility but then you actually do
have to actually solve the problem yeah
because if you're like hey you're right
in and take out that trash you know I
mean you know it won't happen again and
then tomorrow same thing tomorrow same
thing next week same thing same things
you then and you just sort of become the
husband that doesn't take out the trash
and yeah just says yeah it's my fault
kind of thing and you used to become the
that's my bad yeah my bad might be sorry
about that and then that's all you do is
say that it's on me yeah and yes I don't
I mean obviously don't be like no but
Utrecht take out the trash yeah once in
a while and I think you know obviously
don't say that um but you actually do
have to take out the trash you do
problems get solved yeah I learnt that
I'm Junko all right that's a good one
and Dave obviously thank you for coming
on again thanks for your service in the
Marine Corps and for everything you've
done for America
so always an honor to have known you to
have worked with you and it's an honor
to be working with you right now and I
actually want to close out this
conversation with another letter and
it's also written by that same that same
young articulate even poetic Marine
Corps machine gunner Saul Segal who
wrote the letter that opened this
podcast and this one is written to the
cousin of one of his comrades one of his
comrades named James Trowbridge
and the cousin did not know what
happened to her cousin corporal
Trowbridge who had gone missing in World
War one and she didn't know what
happened to him and so this is another
letter written after the end of the war
it's dated February 18th 1920 and it
reads my dear Miss Trowbridge my old
sergeant major Clifford has written me
and has enclosed a copy of your letter
to him in which you request information
concerning your cousin corporal James H
Trowbridge it is indeed unfortunate that
his family should be left so uncertain
concerning his sad end I know that it
has been the cause of great concern with
you I am sorry to that I had not known
of this before for I was the last of his
friends to see him alive though sergeant
Clifford wrote me January 16th I have
been out adventuring in the oil fields
of northern Texas and I have only lately
ventured back into civilization your
letter was forwarded to me from my home
in Ohio and I received it tonight and
I'm taking this first occasion to answer
it I hope it will clear up Jim's case if
there's anything I can do in the future
any service I can perform any advice I
can offer to Jim's folks I will be at
their service at all times we who have
survived this hell on earth counted the
least we can do to console the sorrowing
mothers and families of our dead
comrades in arms I still remember when I
first met Jim it was in Bella woods on
the 13th of June we were making ready
for the attack when replacements arrived
to fill up our broken ranks Jim was
assigned to my gun crew and the way he
went over the top like the brave soldier
he always was and his subsequent act
made me his proud friend and comrade to
the day he went west
I still remember one night on guard with
Jim in the little hole alongside the
night held an eerie stillness a night
fit for such a hellhole I was deathly
tired and though there was no wire only
an empty space between the Germans and
us
I slept then Jim like the good pal he
was kept watch until the officer of the
watch came by when he awakened me that I
might not be shot for sleeping at my
post it was for deeds like that that
every man in the company idolized him
and I can assure you that Jim Trowbridge
name and memory will forever be held in
reverence by the survivors of the 23rd
company so many men were wounded and
left us then came back during the
battles that followed Bela Woods to the
last phase of the Argonne drive that I
must confess ignorance as to whether Jim
was or not you see Jim was assigned to a
crew of his own and the machine gun of
his own and on the battle line the
number 1 and number 10 gun may be in the
same company yet they are a world apart
each carries on and knows that the other
is carrying on and so the battle is won
yet I dimly remembered that Jim was
either gassed or wounded in the
champagne drive in which the second
division captured Mont Blanc Ridge it
began on October 2nd 1918 Jim came back
to us before the last phase the Argonne
drive which began on November 1st 1918
through the mud and rain and fog we
pushed forward over the top that
glorious day the second division leading
the whole army
we captured every piece of Bose field
artillery white-hot they were and we
sent the Germans scurrying back and
broke their invincible line to bits
my company suffered terribly and dead
and wounded yet we carried on hungry and
tired and facing the everlasting hail of
bullets and shells we pushed forward for
six days battling steadily the 6th of
November rows dismal II I remember
passing Jim by the roadside and he gave
me a cheery hail then he followed up the
rear we went forward and the Bose began
shelling us as the last of the column
came up I heard from them that Jim's
crew had rested once again by the
roadside none of us were strong we had
not eaten in days
a great shell had exploded and had
killed and wounded all of Jim's crew Jim
had had a foot torn off by a flying
fragment there was death and destruction
all about I volunteered to help carry a
wounded man back to the first aid
station there was Jim lying on the
blanketed floor I knelt down to speak to
him I marked that his face was already
drawn with pain and that he was gray
from long exposure and loss of blood he
said Saul old pal I'm dying good luck to
you old man I tried to cheer him up but
to no avail
on the battlefield one knows when death
approaches that is all I know
for a few hours later I was knocked out
myself yet I doubt not that Jim went
west a home and two mother
soon after whether Jim died and was
buried in the village a few miles south
of sedan in the Ardennes Department or
whether he survived until he reached the
hospital I do not know you can find out
by writing the graves registration
Bureau at Washington that he is gone I
am reasonably sure I would advise his
family to harbor no unfounded hopes in
his safety it is with deep regret that I
asked yours and Jim's mother's pardon
for my heartless and brutal description
of this story my experiences on the
battlefield have caused me to use other
than tender words that might sue the
brokenhearted mother
believe me nevertheless that I grieve
with her for her son and my comrade then
believe me to that I stand ready to do
all in my power to assist her in any
possible way it is hard I know yet at
such a cost has liberty and democracy
survived except my dear miss Trowbridge
the assurance of my profound respect
most sincerely Saul Segal
so liberty and democracy survived but at
such a cost and so many bore that cost
the fighting that salsa gal writes about
was part of the meuse-argonne offensive
as part of the hundred days offensive
that brought the war to an end and while
bringing the war to the end it cost the
lives of twenty six thousand two hundred
and seventy seven Americans in corporal
James Trowbridge was one of those
Americans he died around the 6th of
November 1918 and as we know the
armistice was signed then the war ended
just five days later on November 11th
war is hell than the cost of liberty and
the cost of democracy is immense and I
started this podcast we were talking
about that quote the quote that says
when you know the way broadly you see in
everything well in that vein I think
that if you know the cost broadly if you
know the cost of freedom then you see it
and you appreciate it
in everything in everything that we have
been given especially our most precious
gift and that is freedom
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight and I think at this point echo
if you want to maybe give us an
opportunity to decompress or sure maybe
we could help you talk about how we can
take advantage of the freedom that we
have yes sir
cool we'll do both okay look and support
yourself too by the way
deeper so first we'll talk about origin
I know a little bit of a rough
transition cuz yeah that's house cuz
that's it that's a letter right there
yeah again 20 what now he's so now he's
20 2019-20 he's 22 years old Dave yeah
unreal
yeah I tried to figure out what happened
to him like what where where he went
did he take over like a big company he
must have done something awesome Saul
Segal seagull seagull
yeah it's se GE l should have become a
writer they should have the absolutely
become a writer yeah you know you read
these letters and again you say the
whole time but you kind of can't help
but remember especially the skin letters
that like this actual person it's not
just some cool letter you know kind of
thing it's like this actual person
writing this letter to an actual person
just like about an actual person yeah
about James Trowbridge yeah crazy all
right well I guess we can talk about
origin made in America
I guess there's that there's that so
yeah so again origin yes so they have
American made products good products too
as in the best
yeah I think they're the best but here's
the thing you know what people like yeah
they got the best being it's like it's a
matter of opinion so I can't tell you
they're the best but I can't tell you I
think can you not say it's the best key
yeah oh it's the best key Hogan
factually that's a fact really thing
yeah so geez
so yeah if on the path we're on the path
Dave Burke you're on the path to pass
you just as part of that path optional
for sure optional but it is part of the
path it's not not part of the path
assume saying he might be questioning
whether it's optional ya know cuz you've
heard of people who don't necessarily do
jujitsu but they're on the path yeah you
if you yeah you should try and train
jiu-jitsu though is my recommendation
it's like strongly recommend Dave
recommendation yea or nay
Jiu Jitsu it's not a recommendation you
need to do it yeah it's weird it's just
it's something unlike anything else I've
ever done and it's something you need to
do and it's there's a million different
reasons to do it and it's look echo it's
not an option if you're on the path
you're training but not word by the way
representing the origin t-shirt big time
if someone's wondering yeah the designee
boy
so yeah boom there you go so when you
start you Jitsu or if you're already you
need a new gear origin geek best one
made in America hundred percent Cotton's
made in America they make with with
other stuff obvious it's you know Agee
they got rash guards and other jujitsu
stuff on there as well or gin main calm
joggers okay how you feel about joggers
overall I mean we've come a long way
let's face it we're talking about me the
view are you indicating that I have made
some movement towards I'm gonna be
sporting a pair of joggers if that's
what you're thinking it's not you know
there's been no movement no movement
still at move one pre phase one previous
one yep they're not happening for me
would you see anti joggers possibly
because I've been wearing a lot not
answer I don't look at people and say oh
man I can't believe that guys wearing
joggers I don't care about it that much
right but so but it's still like it's a
zero it's not a negative yes just an
idea of job zero well is something I
don't get yeah yeah I dig it man
things that you know you might get
nonetheless I am not in that boat a lot
of things I'm saying there are things
that you kinda you know don't get right
on overall depends on what you mean by
over anyway
joggers t-shirts obviously Dave Burke
representing big-time hardcore if you
will big dive time huge time actually
yeah look at that shirt it's dope anyway
there there are literature sweats as
well you know sweat suit most
comfortable in the world that's
factually that's like not even matter
opinion sure sounds like it's not though
also supplements okay Burke you're on
the dis okay there's supplements right
jock will super krill oil mm-hmm three
joints omega-3s all that antioxidants in
there all kinds of stuff good for your
joints legitimately yeah not this you
don't want a day the commercial thing
this is for real good for your joints
that's that joint warfare good for your
joints in a different way but very good
free joints discipline good for your
brain good for your muscles called
discipline pre workout pre cognitive not
precognitive but pre mission we'll call
it cognitive enhancing neutral okay well
you know who's down with the discipline
Dave Burke I am down with the discipline
what when do you take it I take it
usually twice a day so get up workout
I'm tracking for a while at about 10:00
10:30 and I that's about the time I sit
down and I have to I got a grind at my
computer and I really don't want to but
I need to and I got to put my brain
anything I will take discipline and I
will crank for a while and then the
other time I do it is typically like
post bedtime the kids and I would I'd
really like to do is just call it a day
oh but I but I can get some yeah I got
that and that's that's what I'll take it
yeah what about pre jujitsu I every time
I go train on the drive I thought needs
to be like well no not really
no every time I go dream I was mixing
one up at the house today
mm-hm and he's like Oh are we going
wrong I was like yeah you have to
religious schools there these are
keeping scooter I think it might end up
being poor and I don't know if you
noticed this but I had a pretty small
water bottle yeah so I'm I'm mixing up
these supercharged I haven't eaten it
before it doesn't taste good brah right
you know and I haven't done it if I had
to but anyway so that's discipline yeah
I did and and then you you take mole
again this is good that you're here cuz
I tell everyone it tastes good that to
me but I'm only one person you like it
to mince your flavor too right okay so
here's the thing I gotta explain that
because you're here Dave Burke you're
here you're on the discipline screen I
dig it wasn't even like college days a
number of episodes ago I would say more
than once by the way that I'm like
protein powder that's what the kids
takes to make them think they're getting
big whatever right that's kind of how I
felt about it and I you know I okay okay
we'll say that but okay so Pete sent me
the vanilla he's in a blank yeah yeah
yeah so it's kind
yeah something like cool I put any I was
like dang this is pretty good yeah
introduced vanilla by the way yeah so
it's not a good flavor right I think
even like one of the definitions of
vanilla is like it's just oh it's fine
we're not excited about vanilla yeah but
it's good I got a little bit excited so
like but it could be my bias
you know it's Pete you know thanks P you
get the big box you're all excited it
could be you know you can be biased
results so I'm like all right you know
what the test is here's the test I have
a one-year or two-year he's almost - oh
yeah so I'm like all right let me
absolutely give it to him I don't
recommend giving them a bunch I don't
know if all the protein 22 grams of
protein by the way yeah two grams of
sugar no 1 gram of sugar - total carbs
two grams of fat by the way which I mean
feel how you want to feel about fat like
it's a little bitter but Brad this is a
for real protein deal like you want
extra protein they're not gonna give you
a bunch of stuff you didn't sign up for
anyway side note
so I'm like okay my son's do you have a
real problem with things that you don't
sign up for I notice that about that's
one of your things you don't you sign up
for something and it comes anyways you
don't like that unless it's a box of
good stuff from Pete then you didn't
sign up for a buddy like it there is
that yes so boom I give it to them mix
it up milk by the way just to be in the
spirit of accuracy boom hit it yeah you
liked it so I'm like oh okay but it
could be one of those things was that
meant or was that vanilla vanilla
yeah so I'm like alright why could it be
anomaly you know you give like someone
that maybe thought I don't know taste it
you know some he's like more more more
so I'm trying to get out my phone so I
can take a video to send to Pete and
he's like Laurie's kind of tripping so
I'm like alright so finally get the
video going and I give it to him yeah he
wants it mm-hmm what's the Mulk to
harold drinking mo not to say to give it
to you to your I'm saying as a taste
test that works because and that's been
vanilla by the way so anyway just
confirmed confirmed and that's vanilla
so I like the the mint chocolate we are
hundred-percent and peanut butter
chocolate is now live at origin mein
kampf
is that official that was official
that's official yes all right
that is official so all my Twitter
competition of who's gonna get the verse
peanut butter chocolate is on it's good
- it's good because I've had it because
we we test it and we went through like
three it didn't the cool thing is it
didn't take that many iterations to get
it it was a little bit more chocolate a
little bit more peanut butter
alright I think was three iterations and
we were good I will say this send it
I don't you please I put like a half a
tablespoon of peanut butter in the
Mitchell by the way as a test and boom I
like that too for that anyway yeah and
don't forget the krill are in the joint
Wharf rats
these are daily things we need this yeah
take it from me we need this so don't
run out also good way to support
and represent because representing is a
method of support my opinion Chuck where
the store it's called choco store you
can get jaco gear rash guards choco gear
like it's like more geared towards the
game mm-hmm get after it all that stuff
anyway yeah rash guards t-shirts
discipline equals freedom all these
things a lot of stuff concepts
conceptually representing by way of
apparel you don't like the word apparel
apparel clothing those things fashion no
okay got you so anyway accessories if
you will some some hats on there some
good stuff to women stuff on there if
you want to represent go to chuckles
doggone that's where you get this stuff
also you want to subscribe to the
podcast if you haven't already seems
obvious I know and that's on stitcher
iTunes Google Play you know all these
places where they play podcasts good way
to support and live review and don't
forget about this podcast also there's a
warrior kid podcast yes so subscribe to
the war warrior kid podcast Dave Burke
was the first guest on the warrior kid
podcast number 16 which is out at this
time if you want to hear him answer
questions from children about being a
Marine Corps fighter pilot and there's
also some stories from Uncle Jake in the
most recent three podcasts 14 15 and 16
there's some stories from uncle Jake
talking about how uncle Jake kind of
established his principles in life so
those are pretty cool and and in
addition to the warrior kid podcast
being available through the various
podcast channels is also available on
youtube on a separate channel from the
jockle podcast youtube channel which has
this podcast on it which is pretty cool
but it also has the custom artistic
artistic videos video I was looking
enhanced and wicked cool videos from
echo Charles with
about whatever about whatever yeah and
well hey they did with this event we
just actually David I just did an event
and they played the warpath video the
good one and it was on no this is legit
on a giant screen with a sick sound
system like yes yeah actually that
legitimately doesn't make me feel yeah
and a big big crystal clear yeah HDTV so
the whole deal and working is the 4k TV
was mass probably and I was like four
feet from it because we were about to
walk onstage so I was real close to it
yeah yeah you are you do your ninja pose
nonetheless the YouTube thing I was
thinking about this too sometimes like
when when podcasts come out not
necessarily art but you know other
podcasts or whatever sometimes they'll
put it on youtube but they'll just have
the image on there oh yeah yeah just for
another source of audio which is good
yeah you got the added dimension where
we do it is a video pot so if you want
to see what Dave Burke looks like if you
don't know I'm saying we're gonna see
what chocolate looks like if for some
reason you don't know boom you can see
looks like I like that picture somebody
posted of what they thought you look
like you know what I'm gonna ask that
question on the soul sure I'm gonna say
what did you think
echo Charles looked like oh you see how
that goes okay yeah that seems like that
what did you think echo Charles looked
like I think it looks exactly the way he
does I was not at least bit surprised oh
you you okay good deal Dave Burke yeah I
knows it man you heard it here actually
wait did you but you didn't hear me
first you met me first right that was
early enough or did you know I guess my
question
that's like I I heard you long before I
met you but you knew well boom there it
is YouTube subscribe if you want if
you'll uh you know good way to support
really good also just switch up your
workout get some kettlebells get some
battle ropes get a jump rope if you
don't have fun get some I just got some
battle ropes bidding coming mm-hmm think
it's good for my workout I got planned
oh and I got some rings boom oh you
think I already had rings how much you
talk
I did not know you did not have rain not
having disappoint I pull a bar you know
that kind but I don't have rings have
rings now come in yet but anyway you go
to on it calm / Jacques good stuff oh
sorry / jaco night job on it calm /
chuckle they got some good workout stuff
on there a lot of good info - that's
where I went when I was when I'm
starting the kettlebell routine mm-hmm
got got the info from there good stuff
get some socks - a psychological warfare
album you can get it album with iTunes
go to Google Play go to mp3 you can get
an album with me talking about why you
shouldn't be weak for the various
reasons that's it that's all we're
saying about it other than to say we are
working on the new psychological warfare
album however each time I say that I
should I should caveat that by saying I
have had a lot of other things to do so
I am the work I have done so far on the
new psychological warfare album is to
begin to consider topics for the next
album I have a small list it will be
rolled out what do you think 100 when a
people not smoking is that really yeah
this first like what someone's out there
that wants to quit smoking yeah okay
alright so we're on that we'll put it
out there the new psychological warfare
we do have a working title which seems
to be sticking pretty well all your
excuses are lies psychological warfare -
that's the one hopefully to be better
than jaws - but not terminated fear but
not terminated - I'm just saying
Terminator 2 was well it was just as
iconic as Terminator 1 even when we're
good then jock a white tee you can get
it on Amazon you can get the dry teabags
and mix it yourself or you can get in a
can and if you get it no big deal you
can deadlift 8,000 pounds way the
warrior Kid books Dave you've read them
I've read that multiple times they're on
reread in the house you got three kids
raises nine seven four and their
feedback is the feedback is solid the
girls love the books
interesting people ask me what about
girls are you gonna write a book for
girls I did write a book
it's called weigh the warrior kids yep
yep agree thing I've seen absolutely my
lessons of universal kids love it my
girls love it girls start a training
jiu-jitsu because of the book that's
awesome
yep do they study oh yeah they study do
they eat a little bit more healthy look
they're on the path no joke here and
there on the mat it's legit that's
awesome and I actually talk to your kids
occasionally and I see that they are in
fact on the path what about the few
manual they have not read the film guild
manual I have read the field manual
feedback feedback feedback is also legit
it is a prescription if you need some
help on getting a thing on the path read
the field manual have you ever read
three pages of the field manual just
just because the Reap ages yeah have you
just been like you know you're sitting
there and it's on your desk and you're
like you know what I'm gonna check I'm
gonna read this real quick yeah so the
thing about the book is the cover of the
book that cover says open this book its
covers awesome and that hardcover is is
legit man they asked me like oh would
you like to roll out the softcover I'm
like oh never no that is not a softcover
book no it is not no there's an iconic
picture they say echo says there's an
iconic picture I think he said conduct
agra for that took the picture had an
incredible day that day sense no for art
okay I didn't say that for the softcover
oh yes I don't care what the picture
looks like there's no soft colors well
it is actually when I said it's an
iconic picture it means less of the
notion or the idea that I took a great
picture or nothing like this I'm saying
that picture that we took in my hallway
hmm one random night my cheap camera
became a picture that's kind of
representative iconic if you will okay
so he's claiming it of you know your
whole he's trying to downplay it it
couldn't be called iconic that I took a
random night no big deal well you look
at where the word kid the picture on the
back of that one I took down to buy is
that iconic not it didn't push me in
that direction necessarily but the one
on the cover disciplines freedom feel oh
yeah you'll is the publisher wanted a
picture of me where I looked more
approachable and there's something about
the warrior kid books that you didn't
mention though you said you wrote a kids
book that's for boys and girls yeah
that's actually a book for adults do ya
know I said not just not just for the
adults there are lessons for the adults
but that book is a great parenting tool
that's legit parenting tool that I now
get to go is that what Mark would do
what would uncle Jake say here and I
actually get to bear it less now because
I just reverence the book that's that's
no joke man that we're ultimately it is
it really is a social plank because the
here's the problem kids do not listen to
their parents kids listen to a certain
percentage of what their parents say and
there's a certain portion of them that
is programmed to rebel against you as a
parent they're programmed that way and
the more you fight it thought worse it's
gonna get you come in from the flank
boom there you go yep true good point
what about davyous is your big night
what about extreme ownership feedback
feedback I have read that book several
times
I've listened to it I referenced the
book constantly because of the work that
we do and I get a lot of feedback on
that book that is the book that when you
talk about when you see it broadly that
quote from Musashi you see it everywhere
that's what that book is yeah because
once you tip on that and once that gets
embedded in your DNA once you start
doing that you will see that everywhere
and that is what's unique about that
book yes the best feedback I've ever
gotten on that book from people we work
on until they say it just makes sense
yeah we have a follow-on to that book
coming out it's called the dichotomy
leadership it's about
all those opposing forces you face as
leader and I talked about the ultimate
dichotomy tonight and so that book comes
out September 25th
also if you need live training you need
a little bit more than the book you need
a little bit more than the podcasts you
can bring us inside your organization we
have a company called echelon front
that's what Dave was talking about
tonight I was talking about tonight all
the companies that we work with that's
what we're talking about we solve
problems through leadership boom me Lafe
JP Dave Burke Flynn Cochran and now we
also have Mike Cirelli
in the house all right what about the
mustard mustard six coming up San
Francisco this will be my fifth muster
oh yes sorry you missed the first did I
did not make the first muster but this
muster like every other muster is a
going to be awesome and B it's gonna
sell out yeah actually it's gonna sell
it's almost there yeah I talked to Jimmy
just the other day about it we are
tracking way ahead of where we expected
yeah it's gonna sell out soon you got to
get on it no because of the muster we
actually designed something else because
we wanted to do something first of all
the mustards got a pretty high price
point it's pretty expensive and it
focuses on real broad leadership across
the board but we have had come to all
the musters law enforcement military
border patrol firefighters paramedics
other first responders we wanted to do
something a little bit a little bit
focused on what they do for a living
so we have something called the roll
call it is September 21st in Dallas
Texas it's one day leadership seminar
for everyone out there in uniform so if
you're a police officer if you're a
firefighter and we've worked with police
officers and firefighters and we've
worked with border patrol and we've work
with military units and we still do all
of that but if you want to come and get
a one-day immersion into the combat
leadership principles
that we talked about in the book extreme
ownership that we talk about on this
podcast come to the roll call Sept own
September 21st in Dallas Texas and for
both the muster and the roll call you
can register for those at extreme
ownership dot-com on top of all of that
we have something now called national on
front over watch EF over watch calm and
Dave you've been involved pretty heavily
in us standing that up we are we in our
business working with companies we are
always running into companies that need
what do they need they need good leaders
they need good people and because of our
connections to the military all of us
having spent extended periods of time in
the military and special operation as
combat pilots we have connections there
and this is a place where we have an
opportunity to bring those two things
together people that want great leaders
and people that are great leaders that
need jobs so we're bringing those
together whether you're somebody wants
to employ people or whether you're
looking to be employed as a spec ops
individual or a combat pilot then go to
EF overwatch comm put your information
in there and we will proceed down the
line of getting you the best people you
can and I miss anything on EF overwatch
yeah it's it's like you said and the
best thing for the transitioning folks
if you're looking for a new mission to
find your next mission after you
transition out of the service this is
the place to do it
come and get some and if you want to
kind of keep carrying on this
conversation with us virtually that is
until we see you alive either at the
muster or at the roll call or at the
immersion camp up in Maine then you can
find us all on the interwebs on Twitter
on Instagram and
Dave is at David our Burke BER ke
that's the thing I mean you always
forget your own thing
you're like Dave our Burke yeah David
our Burke correct yeah these where you
are and you're there you're there on
Twitter and on Instagram
yep and on that echo is of course echo
Charles and I am at Chaco like echo
anything else nope
good to see you again Dave Burke
actually you talk about him always
texting you about digits and stuff he
calls me to thinking yeah yeah yeah it's
great yeah that's how it is one of those
things where you see his name on your
phone you can't get happy yeah
just for you know you get happy in you
like man was an armlock question escape
at the mouth question real all that
stuff good deal deep great to see ya lil
Dave Burke any closing comments dude
thanks for having me back man I could do
this all day I appreciate the chance to
talk again and being a part of this is a
big deal for me thank you
yeah man awesome to have you on and
again thanks for everything that you've
done for me and done for our freedom as
a nation and I'm sure we will do this
many times again in the future so yeah
this is just the beginning my brother
right now and everyone else in the
military that is out there right now
protecting our freedom thank you and to
the first responders police law
enforcement Border Patrol firefighters
paramedics thanks for keeping us and our
families safe and to everyone else that
is listening thank you thank you for
listening thank you for supporting and
thanks for remembering the heroes that
gave their lives so that Liberty and
democracy can survive and let the names
of the Fallen forever
forever be as on perishable as those
glorious ideals for which they made the
ultimate sacrifice and until next time
this is Dave and Ecko and Jocko ow